Und damit wäre es wieder einmal soweit. Wie immer an jedem letzten Donnerstag im Monat gibt es hier auf Fritz im Blumen das Chaos Radio. Also das Radio, wo seltsame Gestalten, die sich oft mit dem Titel Hacker bezeichnen, das Studio übernehmen, für ganze zwei Stunden über ein Thema reden, von dem sie denken, dass es interessant ist oder dass ihr es hören solltet oder möglicherweise sogar beides. Und heute sind zu Gast jemand, den ihr vom letzten Mal schon kennt, Starbuck, hallo und guten Abend. Ach nee, du bist ja der, der sein Mikrofon selber aufmachen muss. Drück mal da drüben hinter deinem Rechner, da ist ein Knopf. Ja, genau, drüber. Herzlich willkommen, Herr Starbuck.
Schönen guten Abend.
Dann Leon. Und die beiden sind vor allem deswegen hier um den Stargast des Abends, quasi nämlich unser Commander Hexfield für heute, kurz begrüßen. Das ist Lars Weiler. Hallo Lars.
Hallo Markus.
Und wir haben uns heute in dieser Kombination zusammengefunden, um über ein Thema zu sprechen, das möglicherweise schon immer präsent gewesen ist, das aber gerade in den letzten Wochen wieder ein bisschen Auftrieb erhalten hat. Nein, wir reden nicht über den Überwachungsskandal, der uns tatsächlich immer wieder beschäftigt, sondern wir reden über den Weltraum. Unendliche Weiten. Und der Film Gravity. Der jetzt gerade in den Kinos ist. Und jetzt hätte ich so ein bisschen dafür gesorgt, dass man sich so fragt, ja, dieses Weltraum Ding. Also ich meine, der ist ja jetzt da, der Weltraum da. Also wenn man da so hochfliegt, da kommt irgendwann Weltraum. Was ist denn da eigentlich los? Was kann man da machen? Kann man da nicht auch irgendwie selber was basteln? Und das wollen wir heute hier klären in der Sendung. Also was das denn mit dem Weltraum auf sich hat und warum man sich vielleicht auch als Hacker dafür interessiert. Insbesondere seid auch ihr eingeladen, mit zu sprechen über den Weltraum und vielleicht mal rauszufinden, was ihr davon haltet, dass man sich überhaupt damit beschäftigt. Also soll man da rausfliegen? Würdet ihr da rausfliegen? Oder sagt ihr, dieses ganze Weltraumding, das ist doch einfach total verschwendetes Geld.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110 So Herr Weiler, du beschäftigst dich mit dem Weltraum.
Du bist nicht selber Astronaut?
Nee, leider nicht.
Auch diesen Unterschied werden wir heute noch klären. Wie bist du aber dazu gekommen? Geh mal bitte ein bisschen näher ins Mikrofon. Wie bist du aber dazu gekommen, nicht mit dem Weltraum? Warum ist der Weltraum wichtig? So rum gefragt. Warum ist der Weltraum wichtig?
Na Weltraum, unendliche Weiten. Wie bin ich dazu gekommen? Ich denke mal, so ein einsteinendes Erlebnis für mich war die Columbia Katastrophe.
Die Mondlandung?
Nee, die Mondlandung ist ein bisschen lange vor meiner Zeit gewesen. So alt bin ich auch nicht Starbuck. Nee, tatsächlich die Columbia Katastrophe, die wir 2003 hatten, wo dieses eine Shuttle da auf dem Anflug wieder auf die Erde zerbrochen ist, was ich damals halt irgendwie so live im Internet gesehen hab.
Ich sag's, der Katastrophentourist.
Ja, so ein bisschen schon, ja. Nee, und das hat mich dann irgendwie so ein bisschen dazu gebracht, mehr mich mit der Technik auseinanderzusetzen, einfach mal zu schauen, was ist da los, wie funktioniert das ganze Ding überhaupt, warum ist das Teil auseinandergebrochen, mir das Ganze mal anzulesen, immer weiter reinzusteigen, immer tiefer reinzusteigen, was haben wir überhaupt für Raumschiffe und wie fliegen wir überhaupt in den Weltraum und warum auch?
Gibt es darauf eine Antwort, warum fliegen wir in den Weltraum?
Ist toll da draußen, ist es ruhig, aber endlich.
Ja gut, aber jetzt gibt es gerade diesen Film Gravity und in dem Film geht es darum, dass man in Gefahr gerät, nur weil irgendwelche Satelliten mal auseinander platzen und auf einmal eine riesige Wolke von Trümmern durch die Gegend fliegt und alles zum Schutt und Asche legt.
Na ja, eigentlich geht es im Film anfangs ja darum, dass das Hubble-Weltraumteleskop repariert wird. Es ist halt ein Objekt, was genommen wird, um tiefer in den Weltraum reinzuschauen. Also ein Teleskop, was hier auf der Erde nicht so gut sein würde, weil wir hier, vor allem hier in so einer Stadt, die ein ganzes Mock haben, Wolken auch. Wenn man jetzt noch zum Sternenhimmel raufschaut, dann sieht man die Sterne nur sehr schwach da draußen, weil gerade mal so eine leichte Wolkensticht drüber hängt. Das haben wir alles da oben gar nicht. Das heißt, wir können dort mal ganz klar in den Weltraum reinschauen. Dafür wurde halt so ein Teleskop gebaut, um noch tiefer reinzuschauen.
Nur um diese Verbindung klarzumachen, weil sie vielleicht manche Leute fragen, der Chaos Computer Club, das sind doch die Leute, die immer in einer Technik rumbasteln und die, wie heißt das, zerforschen, ist glaube ich so ein Wort, was gerne benutzt wird. Nur mal ganz kurz, wir kommen später ausführlich in die Runde, nur noch ganz kurz, an welchen Projekten arbeiten tatsächlich auch einzelne Menschen? Nur ganz kurz Beispiele, damit man sozusagen schon weiß, wohin wir noch hin, wo wir noch hinwollen in dieser Sendung.
Satelliten, das heißt selber Satelliten bauen, in den Weltraum schicken und mit denen kommunizieren. Vor allem Kommunikationssatelliten. Dann Raketen, es gibt Leute, die bauen selber Raketen.
Warte, warte, lass mich an dieser Stelle zusammenfassen. Es gibt einzelne Personen oder sozusagen, oder kleine Teams, die im übertragenen Sinne in ihrer Garage Raketen bauen.
Ja, Garage oder im Hackspace halt, was man halt auch mal da hat. Also Garagen-Frigge, da gibt es ja weniger hier so bei uns. Tatsächlich ja, die dann in ihrem Raum Raketen bauen, aber die dort halt nicht direkt in der Stadt irgendwie starten lassen. Aber es gibt durchaus Möglichkeiten hier auf irgendwelchen alten verlassenen Plätzen, größeren Gebieten oder irgendwo in Ostdeutschland halt mal Raketen zu starten.
Die dann in den Weltraum fliegen?
Na, die erstmal überhaupt mal hochfliegen.
Aber mit dem Ziel später mal in den Weltraum zu fliegen?
Ja, genau, richtig.
Dann müssen wir jetzt natürlich fragen, ab wann ist denn Weltraum? Also was müssen wir denn schaffen, damit wir da oben sind?
Es wurde irgendwann ein bisschen wildkuhlig festgelegt. Also es gibt eine Linie, sagt man 100 Kilometer über dem Erdboden, das ist die sogenannte Kammernlinie. Das heißt, ab 100 Kilometer sind die Einflüsse der Atmosphäre so gering, dass man sagen kann, okay, da oben ist Weltraum. Sprich, da hab ich gut Sauerstoff eh schon nicht mehr. Aber auch andere Teilchen, die halt über der Erde hängen, die sind dort auch nicht mehr vorhanden. Die Gravitation lässt schon ein bisschen nach. Zumindest, wenn ich schnell genug um die Erde herumkreise.
Daran vorbeifallen?
Oder dran vorbeifallen, genau. Das ist im Grunde das, was wir die ganze Zeit machen. Zumindest auf einer Raumstation oder wenn wir im Orbit halt sind, fallen wir dran vorbei. Nee, aber so 100 Kilometer ist tatsächlich diese Linie, die festgelegt wurde. Und alle, die höher als 100 Kilometer über normalen Ozeaniveau geflogen sind, das sind Raumfahrer.
Ah, okay, das sind Raumfahrer. Was sind dann Kosmonauten?
Ja, das ist der russische Begriff für Raumfahrer.
Und was sind Astronauten?
Das war dann der amerikanische Begriff. Genauso gibt es ja noch andere Begriffe, ob es jetzt die Spassionauten sind. Das sind halt die Franzosen oder die Taikonauten. Das ist so von ganz weit draußen. Das sind die, also Taiko für ganz weit weg, der chinesische Begriff für die chinesischen Raumfahrer. Und dann gibt es auch noch die Astronauten. Das ist der österreichische Raumfahrer.
Der eine.
Der eine, genau.
Jetzt habt ihr Hacker euch auch irgendwie so einen eigenen Namen ausgedacht? Weil wenn ihr mal ins... Noch nicht.
Einen eigenen Begriff gar nicht dafür. Ich finde das manchmal auch ein bisschen lächerlich. Da tatsächlich so viele Begriffe für dasselbe. Vor allem, dass sie auch immer noch auf der lateinischen Endung Naut für Seefahrrad landen. Das ist halt, naja, ist halt sehr, sehr komisch. Aber halt Kosmos ist ein schöner Begriff, einfach weil es das Gegenteil von Chaos ist.
Okay, so wie kommen wir denn jetzt in den Weltraum? 100 Kilometer ist ja schon eine ganz schöne Strecke.
Naja, mit einer Rakete eigentlich.
Warum nicht mit einem Fahrstuhl?
Ein Fahrstuhl ging ja auch tatsächlich, ja. Das heißt, ein Fahrstuhl bauen, der hoch genug ist. Momentan haben wir das Problem, da gibt es noch nicht das Material für. Also so ein langes Seil zu bauen, ich meine, das wird ja auch viel zu schwer irgendwie.
Aber wir sind tatsächlich nicht mehr allzu weit davon entfernt. Also halt dieser Space Elevator, die Idee ist dahinter, dass du halt in geostationären Orbit ein langes Kabel hochbringst, also praktisch aufgerollt hochbringst und dann halt in beide Richtungen abrollst, dass halt die Gewichtsverteilung, also sowohl die Anziehungskraft der Erde als auch die Fliehkraft in die andere Richtung die gleichen Werte hält und es praktisch damit stabil bleibt. Und dann rollt es halt die 36.000 Kilometer nach unten und ein bisschen mehr als doppelt so viel, glaube ich, nach oben ab. Und wenn du das dann erstmal da hast, dann kannst du dann tatsächlich dann auch da dein... Deinen Fahrstuhl ranhängen und hochfahren.
Naja, so Fahrzeit irgendwie... Gemütlich Aufzugfahrt ist nicht. Ist schon etwas schneller Aufzugfahrt, aber um halt auf die Höhe zu kommen, bist du auch noch so drei Tage unterwegs. Könnte aber durchaus gemütlicher sein als irgendwie so ein Raketenstart.
Es geht halt einfach nur, das ist eine simple Kostenfrage. Also ich meine, Raketen starten, weißt halt, wie viel das kostet. Im Gegensatz, wenn du halt...
Wie viel kostet das denn?
Welche Währung? Siehst du, du hast halt eine Rakete. Ich sag mal jetzt so zum Beispiel ein Soyuz. Ich meine, die wiegt so 330 Tonnen voll getankt. Und Nutzlast sind irgendwas so 5 Tonnen rum. Kommt drauf an, von wo wir die aus starten, welchen Startplatz wir dafür nehmen. Aber so Nutzlast, so um die 5 Tonnen so ungefähr. Und kannst ja einfach mal ausrechnen, wie viel Sprit da rein muss. Also das Ding besteht eigentlich fast nur aus Sprit, so gesehen. Was wir mit hoch transportieren. Das ist nicht wenig. Also so ein Start kostet echt viel.
Reden wir jetzt über Millionenbeträge, oder?
Es wird meistens pro Kilogramm gerechnet. Also so kleinere Satelliten irgendwie, so Mini-Satelliten, die wir hochschicken würden. Ich mein, das wären so 20.000, 30.000 Dollar.
Ja, aber sobald die Gesamtmissionskosten sind halt auf jeden Fall deutlich im Millionenbereich. Also weil du ja immer eine gewisse Größe brauchst, um überhaupt hoch zu kommen. Und irgendwie, das kostet halt einfach.
Und dann stellen die jetzt Leute hin und wollen das selber bauen?
Na, es wird ja schon mal reichen, kleine Raketen zu haben. Um irgendwie kleine Satelliten hochzubringen. Ich meine, Kommunikationstechnik heutzutage ist ja sehr klein geworden. Jetzt nehmen wir einfach mal so ein Smartphone, was für jeder eine Hosentasche hat, ist nicht groß, wiegt wenig, werden auch immer leichter die Teile. Und die würden schon vollkommen ausreichen, um dort oben so einen Kommunikationssatelliten hinzuschicken, mit dem ich dann reden könnte.
Weißt du, was die kleinste Rakete war, die bisher hochgeflogen ist? Was ist denn so die Minimalausstattung, die man braucht, an Gewicht, um überhaupt hochzukommen?
Minimal hast du eigentlich gar nicht.
Oder das kleinste, was bisher hochgeflogen ist?
Na ja, wir können ja früh mal anfangen. Was war die erste Rakete, die in den Weltraum geflogen ist? Oder zumindest das erste Objekt, das in den Weltraum geflogen ist. Leider auch ein bisschen traurig, das Teil. Das ist die sogenannte Aggregat 4, also war schon die vierte Inkarnation einer Rakete, die gebaut wurde, auch in Deutschland gebaut wurde. Damals war es aber noch das Deutsche Reich, und das Teil wurde dann unter dem anderen Namen Vergeltungswaffe 2 V2 auch eingesetzt, um London zu bombardieren im Zweiten Weltkrieg. Sprich so 1942, 1943 wurde das erste Mal eine Rakete bis in über die 100 Kilometer Linie weggeschossen. Das ist so die Vergangenheit davon. Dieses Teil wurde dann halt später, so nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, geschnappt von den Amis. Die haben das dann einfach mal eingesackt und alles andere, was da gefunden wurde, und haben das in den USA übergebracht. Gleichzeitig haben es auch noch die Wissenschaftler mitgenommen, um dort weiter an Raketentechnik zu entwickeln, die erstmal für militärische Zwecke eingesetzt werden sollen.
Also es war dann tatsächlich von der Größe ja auch so ein V2 Größe, also so irgendwie 20, 30 Meter hoch.
Nee, V2 ist gar nicht mal so groß. V2, das waren irgendwie so 6, 7 Meter oder so. Ich meine, wenn du einen anschauen willst, kannst du mal hier ins Technikmuseum auch in Berlin gehen. Die haben da noch so eine rumstehen.
Echt so klein war die?
Ja, die ist gar nicht mal so groß. Das ist echt ein kleines Teil. Sollte ja nicht weit fliegen, sollte ja nicht so komplett um die Erde rum, sondern nur ein paar hundert Kilometer weiter und relativ schnell. Die waren auch nicht so genau zu der Zeit. Ich meine, es gab ja noch nicht so richtig gute Technik.
Da ging es ja tatsächlich drum, wer es ja auch wieder runterkommt auf den gewissen Umkreis. Aber wenn wir etwas hochschicken wollen, dann muss sie einfach nur hochkommen über die hundert Kilometer. Dann reicht es ja für uns.
Exakt, genau. Das ist aber so eine ballistische Flugbahn, was diese Rakete eingegangen ist. Also es heißt ballistisch, wir kennen uns vom Sportunterricht, wir wollen Ball werfen, werfen einfach mal durch die Gegend, der fliegt dann irgendwie hoch und kommt wieder runter auf die Erde. Das würde natürlich nicht reichen, hochzukommen. Das heißt, was wir haben wollen, ist im Grunde ein Orbit erreichen. Orbit heißt, wir müssen eine sogenannte kosmische Geschwindigkeit überschreiten. Das hört sich jetzt schon toll an. So die erste kosmische Geschwindigkeit. Nee, kann man ausrechnen, irgendwie so eine tolle Formel, irgendwas mit Masse der Erde und Radius und ganz anderen Kram und dann auch irgendwie noch so eine tolle Konstante, die nutrische Gravitationskonstante noch mit reinwerfen. Einfach ein bisschen rumwurzeln, genau. Das Ergebnis bedeutet, ich brauche eine Geschwindigkeit von 7, 91 km pro Sekunde.
Also ungefähr 28.500 kmh.
Richtig. Das heißt, diese Geschwindigkeit muss ich erreichen. Dann schafft es ein Objekt, um die Erde rumzukreisen, ohne auf den Boden wieder rauf zu plumpsen.
Also wie, ich muss jetzt sagen, nach da oben bringen?
Nö, das kannst du auch, wenn du es schaffst, irgendwie so schnell hier ein Objekt auf der Erde zu starten, das kannst du auch hier innerhalb der Erde machen. Das heißt, wenn du ein Objekt hast, was mit der Geschwindigkeit von 28.500 kmh durch die Gegend heizen kann und auch diese Geschwindigkeit halten kann, dann wird es auch nicht auf die Erde runter plumpsen. Natürlich haben wir hier das Problem auf der Erde, dass wir auch die Atmosphäre drin haben. Irgendwas wird bremsen und dann wird es schon runter plumpsen. Deshalb ist der Orbit schon angenehmer, weil da oben habe ich den Widerstand nicht mehr.
Das sind die Konstanten und sagen, um 28.500 kmh zu erreichen, muss ich also ein paar Tonnen Treibstoff verbrennen?
Genau.
Das macht man jedes Mal. Wie ist es denn aber jetzt mit dem, ich baue mir selber so eine Rakete, wer macht denn sowas und wie weit sind die da gekommen?
Ich meine, wir hatten jetzt irgendwie vom CCC hier das Chaos Communication Camp 2011 gehabt. Da hatten wir auch ein paar Leute dabei, die selber so eine Rakete bauen. Die sind jetzt bei ein paar hundert Metern überhaupt mal Hochstaaten. Die bauen halt selber komplett die Motoren. Man sagt tatsächlich Motor dazu. Und die testen das Ganze aus und bringen es halt hoch. Das sind so teilweise Veteranen generell aus der Raketentechnik, Leute, die halt bei unseren Weltraumorganisationen halt hier DLR oder ESA angestellt sind oder Waren, die halt ihren Spaß da noch mit haben. Und die basteln das zusammen und schicken das mal hoch. Momentan die Generation kommt da nicht allzu hoch und kriegt auch noch nicht in Orbit hin. Aber die denken, dass sie es so in fünf bis zehn Jahren gefixt kriegen. Dann können wir selber halt auch mit einzelnen und mit eigenen kleinen Raketen, die gar nicht mehr so teuer sind, auch kleine Satelliten hochschicken.
Also das ist ja tatsächlich Rocket Science. Ich meine, der Begriff kommt ja nicht von ungefähr. Also du musst schon irgendwie ordentlich da Grips reinstecken, um flüssig Treibstoff zusammenzuführen und in der richtigen Verbrennungskammer auf Temperatur zu bringen.
Ja, Starbuck sagt es halt, Verbrennung. Das ist das Problem halt einfach dabei. Ich meine, Verbrennung bedeutet, dass wir auch Sauerstoff haben. Verbrennung funktioniert ja wirklich nur durch Zugabe von Sauerstoff in der Umwelt. Da haben wir keinen Sauerstoff mehr. Das heißt, wir müssen auch diesen ganzen blöden Sauerstoff, den Oxydizer, auch noch mitschleppen. Nicht nur den Treibstoff selber, sondern auch das Ding, was die Verbrennung hinterher erzeugt. Da gibt es halt auch sehr viele Überlegungen, wie wir vielleicht andere Antriebe erstellen.
Gibt es da schon so Science Fiction, der möglicherweise bald real wird?
Nein, die Science Fiction ist schon real. Das ist der sogenannte Ionenantrieb zum Beispiel.
Aber aber nicht, um von der Erde hoch zu kommen, oder?
Nee, von Erde hoch zu kommen nicht.
Das ist tatsächlich nur chemische bisher und wird wahrscheinlich auch so bleiben.
Es gibt schon andere Antriebe, also gedachte Antriebe, die auch sehr weit fortgeschritten sind. Das war das sogenannte Projekt Orion. Das ist so in den 50ern und 60ern entwickelt worden, ist bis in die späten 70er gelaufen, bis dann komplett eingestellt wurde. Atomkraft. Hört sich komisch an?
Um was die erste koschmütige Geschwindigkeit zu machen.
Um generell überhaupt hoch zu fliegen. Das heißt, es wurde eine Rakete entwickelt, ist auch testweise gemacht worden. Zwar nicht mit Atomen in diesem Fall, sondern halt mit Wasserstoffbomben. Aber eine Rakete, die du dir so ein bisschen wie Projektil vorstellen kannst, die hat hinten eine große Platte. Und durch die Platte durch, wird immer wieder so eine kleine Atombombe durchgeschleust, also so ein kleines Loch in der Mitte, kommt so eine kleine Atombombe durch, die explodiert. Und bombt sich nach oben. Genau, also die explodiert dahinter, kleine Atom.
Ist das tatsächlich, um von der Erde hochzukommen? Ich dachte, das wäre tatsächlich nur für...
Geht auch. Kommts auch von der Erde von weg. Vor allen Dingen hat die einen sehr, sehr guten Schub, also auch einen sehr guten, so genannten, spezifischen Impuls.
Entschuldigung, wir reden hier über Atombomben.
Richtig.
Was meinst du, was sie in den 50ern alles irgendwie mit Atombomben machen wollten? So Kanäle sprengen und...
Da können wir wirklich froh sein, und die Wissensstaffler, die dann auch gesagt haben, wir wollen das Projekt nicht weiter verfolgen, weil wir haben einfach mal ausgerichtet, jeder Start von einer dieser Raketen würde so großen Vollort geben, dass mindestens zehn Personen sterben werden auf der Erde. Oder noch mehr. Ganz davon abgesehen, was für viele Tiere oder sonstige Umweltprobleme wir noch hätten. Deshalb gab es dann späte Überlegungen mit normalen, normalen sag ich es schon mal, mit einer Rakete zu starten, also mit einem Flüssigstoffantrieb oder Feststoffbooster hochzubringen und die Atomreaktionen oder die Atombomben in der ersten Welt zu zünden.
Oder halt die Atomenergie, um halt normal die Energie für die Satelliten zu benutzen. Da gab es doch vor ein paar Jahren das große Problem oder den Aufschrei, dass sie die Plutoniumbatterie eingebaut haben in die Satelliten und dann Angst hatten, dass wenn die Rakete jetzt beim Start kaputt geht, dass irgendwie die halbe Erde verseucht wird.
Es ist sehr häufig sogar so, dass du kleine Atomreaktoren auf Satelliten drauf hast, also vor allen Dingen Satelliten, die weiter wegfliegen ins Sonnensystem. Da klappen die Solarpanele auch nicht mehr so gut.
Genau, das ist halt die einzige sichere Energiequelle.
Also hätten wir die Atomkraft nicht, hört sich jetzt blöd an, ich bin nicht so ein großer Befürworter der Atomkraft, aber hätten wir diese jetzt nicht, wären zum Beispiel Sonden wie Voyager gar nicht mehr so weit rausgekommen aus so einem System.
Ja, das ist ganz spannend, irgendwie die Energie. Das sind Plutoniumbatterien und dieses Plutonium, was sie dort verwendet haben, ist tatsächlich von den ganzen alten Atomtests, also Abfallprodukten der Atomtests. Also sie sind jetzt gerade so, dass sie ganz wenig von diesen Plutonium noch da haben und jetzt gerade wieder überlegen, wie sie denn jetzt neues Plutonium herstellen können, um halt diese Plutoniumbatterien für die nächsten Generationen der Satelliten aufzu...
Wir haben ja gerade eine Wortmeldung zur Atombombenantrieb. Ihr könnt wie gesagt gerne anrufen bei der ganzen Sendung. 0371 77 97 110. So ein bisschen Überfrage an euch, wäre so Weltraum, brauchen wir das überhaupt? Also sollen wir da das ganze Geld drauf werfen? Was wollen wir denn überhaupt? 0331 77 97 11. So und der Markus hat angerufen. 20 Jahre aus Perleberg. Hallo Markus. Hallo? Guten Tag. Du bist jetzt im Radio, Markus. Du wolltest was zu deinem Abtum-Bomben-Mantrieb sagen.
Ja, also ich finde es allgemein ziemlich schlecht, weil es ja ziemlich schlechte Auswirkungen auf die Menschheit hat. Und also ich würde mal sagen, was den Weltraum allgemein angeht, sollten wir uns daran gar nicht interessieren, weil wir leben ja auf der Erde und nicht auf einem anderen Planeten.
Ja, aber wie lange leben wir noch hier?
Die Antwort kannst du jetzt im Radio hören, die geben wir dir gerne natürlich. Klar, sicher, also Atomantrieb ist nicht so doll und auch generell diese Verschmutzung, sei es die Erde oder sei es Weltraum, sollten auch nicht weiter betreiben, also sprich Atomtests oben zu machen. Ich meine mittlerweile sind auch viele Raumfahrtagenturen, die Satelliten auch auf ferne Monde hinwegschicken auch so weit, dass sie sagen, wir bohren zum Beispiel gar nicht mal in irgendwelche Eisschichten rein oder so auf Monde, die existieren, weil könnte ja sein, dass wir diese verseuchten mitgebrachten Mikromen, die wirklich diesen ganzen langen Flug durchs All noch überstanden haben.
Wir waren gerade noch bei Atombombenkrieg, jetzt sind wir bei Mikro auf aller Mond langsam, langsam, nicht mit 28.500 kmh durch die Sendung. Also Raketenantrieb ist teuer, jetzt Atombomben wurde es probiert. Ich will noch mal zurückkommen auf diese eine Stelle, du wirst mich da nicht los, nämlich so dieses, das bauen Leute gerade selber. Ja. Wir sind also, die sind so weit, dass sie in fünf bis zehn Jahren, hast du glaube ich gesagt, dass sie dann auch wirklich da ganz hoch sind. In welcher Preisklasse reden wir da? Es ist dann wirklich so, also wird es sozusagen, klar, es ist Raketentechnik, es muss gemacht werden, es kostet wahrscheinlich auch eher so Geld wie ein teures Hobby. Also sowas wie, keine Ahnung, Motorradfahren oder so. Aber kommt man, ist es sozusagen nicht Science Fiction, dass man tatsächlich überlegt, wenn man will, kann dann über kurz oder lang jeder was in den Weltraum schicken?
Na, ich glaube, jeder nicht. Also du brauchst ja schon einiges an Hintergrundwissen dafür, also einiges auch an Bildung, um das Ganze mal durchzurechnen.
Nee, ich meine gar nicht mehr so sehr, dass man das wieder selber bauen kann, sondern eher sozusagen, dass es so einfach wird, dass es möglicherweise ein Angebot gibt, also dass man es so einfach herstellen kann, dass es vielleicht lohnt irgendwie. Hier, kauf deine kleine Rakete.
Na, das jetzt schon. Also ich meine, auch Angebot, Sachen im Weltraum zu bringen, ja. Das gibt es ja jetzt schon. Das heißt, du kannst ja da Startplätze auf Raketen mitkaufen für deine Satelliten. Also das ist ja schon kommerziell, das ist ja ganz groß kommerziell. Ich meine, selbst die Leute, die jetzt hier uns gerade per Radio über ein Satellit hören, das sind alles kommerzielle Satelliten, die eingekauft wurden, also bzw. deren Startplätze eingekauft wurden.
Ja, aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich noch sozusagen, wir reden da über fünf bis sechsstellige Beträge.
Naja, wenn das Geld hast.
Aber darum ging es mir doch gerade.
Du meinst wirklich günstige Möglichkeiten, was in den Weltraum zu bringen.
Okay, lass es mich so formulieren, du hast ja gesagt, irgendwie im Prinzip reicht es, ein Smartphone ins Weltall zu schießen. Da hätte man schon was von. So, dieses Ding. Wann wird es für jedermann oder arbeiten wir darauf hin, dass es für jedermann möglich ist, einen kleinen Satelliten ins Weltraum zu schießen?
Ich denke schon. Also es geht schon in diese Richtung rein, ja. Und ich denke mal, dass wir so in 10, 15 Jahren soweit sind, dass wir schnell und einfach Sachen in den Weltraum bringen können. Die Frage ist, ob da Platz ist dann.
Das ist in der Tat eine spannende Frage, um die wir uns gleich kümmern werden. Wir wissen jetzt also schon mal, wie wir in den Weltraum kommen und dass das immer einfacher wird und demnächst kennen wir dann mal, was wir dort eigentlich wollen. Vorher gibt es die Nachrichten mit Schwerpunktverkehr und ihr könnt ja noch anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110, wenn ihr wollt. Ansonsten hören wir uns gleich wieder. Bis dann.
Lauschen wir nun dem russischen Staatsüberhaupt Vladimir Putin. Wir übersetzen Simulant.
Nur ganz kurz zu der Frage, warum mein schönes Russland so etwas wie dieses Fritz unabhängig finanziert durch einen Rundfunkbeitrag auf gar keinen Fall braucht.
Ganz einfach, solche unabhängigen Medien wie Fritz machen nur Ärger. Da kann man gar nicht in Ruhe regieren und regiert werden. Unser schönes Russland ist auch ohne sowas ein freies Land. Denn hier kann schließlich jeder machen, was ich will. Ich bin Michael und jetzt jubelt!
Unabhängig durch euren Rundfunkbeitrag, einfach für alle um kurz vor halb elf.
Der frühere US-Geheimdienst-Mitarbeiter Snowden ist offenbar bereit vor einem Untersuchungsausschuss des Bundestages zur Spionage-Affäre auszusagen. Das sagte der grünen Bundestag-Abgeordnete Ströbele dem ARD-Magazin Panorama. Ströbele hat Snowden in seinem russischen Exil getroffen. Das dreistündige Treffen mit dem ex-NSA-Mitarbeiter habe unter strengster Geheimhaltung stattgefunden, hieß es weiter. Die USA suchen Snowden mit Haftbefehl und werfen ihm Landesverrat vor. Der US-Geheimdienst NSA überwacht offenbar noch mehr deutsche Spitzenpolitiker als bisher bekannt. Die New York Times berichtet, dass die NSA nicht nur das Handy von Bundeskanzlerin Merkel überwacht hat, sondern auch die Telefone von ranghohen Beamten und den Chefs der Oppositionsparteien. An den Späheraktionen soll nach weiteren Medienberichten auch die US-Botschaft in Berlin beteiligt sein, mit Hilfe von Spionageanlagen auf dem Dach des Hauses am Pariser Platz. Botschafter Amazon wies die Vorwürfe im RWB zurück. Kein Alkoholverkauf mehr am Abend, das fordert ein Netzwerk von elf deutschen Großstädten, darunter ist auch Potsdam. Die Städte meinen, dass es mehr Jugendkriminalität und Komasaufen gibt, weil Jugendliche spät abends noch Alkohol kaufen können. Das Netzwerk forderte die Bundesregierung auf, den Verkauf zeitlich einzuschränken. Außerdem müsse stärker kontrolliert werden, ob Supermärkte, Spätis und Tankstellen Alkohol an unter 18-Jährige verkaufen. Die Koalitionsverhandlungen zwischen Union und SPD sind heute nur wenig vorangekommen. Die Parteien einigten sich darauf, die Energiewende weiter voranzutreiben und die Kosten dafür zu begrenzen. Wie das genau aussehen soll, ist aber noch unklar. Bei anderen Themen sind sich Union und SPD dagegen noch nicht einig. Sie streiten sich zum Beispiel über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und darüber, ob der Verfassungsschutz von Köln nach Berlin umziehen soll. Die aktuellen Temperaturen liegen in Berlin und Brandenburg zwischen minus einem und sieben Grad. Heute Nacht dichte Wolken und etwas Regen. Die Temperaturen gehen auf sechs bis minus zwei Grad dann runter. Morgen Vormittag gibt es nur in der Lausitz ein bisschen Sonnenschein. Danach wird es aber auch da, wie sonst überall in Berlin und Brandenburg bewölkt. Es kann auch immer mal regnen bei maximal 13 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin Altglienige, die Wegedornstraße, ist zwischen Semmelweisstraße und Rudower Straße wegen Arbeiten an Gasleitungen gesperrt. Nach Brandenburg A13, Dresden Richtung Berlin, zwischen Lübbenau und Dumen sind in beiden Richtung Tiere auf der Fahrbahn. Frau Dortbitte, besonders vorsichtig. Und noch ein paar Meldungen zum Personennahverkehr zur S-Bahn Berlin. Für die S2 fahren zwischen Marienfelde und Priesterweg bis zum 8. November weiterhin Busse. Bis Betriebsschluss fahren auch für die S1 zwischen Birkenwerder und Oranienbus ersatzweise Busse. Und zum RE1 zwischen Berlin-Ostbahnhof und Erkner fahren bis zum 4. November ersatzweise Busse. Ihr könnt auf die S-Bahn-Linie 3 ausweichen. Kommt gut durch die Nacht.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Heute Chaos Radio in Blue Moon und wir begeben uns in den Weltraum. Denn auch das ist für Hacker interessant. Natürlich ist ja eine Herausforderung. Und deswegen sind ein paar Leute vom Chaos Computer Club da und reden mal darüber, was man im Weltraum alles für Unfug treiben kann. Ich begrüße herzlich noch mal Lars, Leon und Starbuck.
Hallo. Wo du gerade Unfug treiben redest, wir hatten vorhin gerade noch die Diskussion zum Thema, also was wirklich Hacker im Weltraum suchen, Satelliten. Also es gibt durchaus ausgediente und noch aktive Satelliten, die halt auch ein Betriebssystem drauf haben, wo man nicht nur Daten abhören kann, die runterkommen, sondern sich durchaus auch einloggen kann.
Okay, gut. Ich wollte in dieser halben Stunde jetzt eh darüber reden. Wir haben jetzt in der ersten halben Stunde geklärt, wie kommen wir da hoch? Und jetzt fangen wir an, was machen wir da eigentlich? Und bevor wir über Menschen reden, das machen wir auch noch, reden wir jetzt mal über genau diese Dinge, Satelliten. Das ist ja ein interessantes Ding. Ich so als Nicht-Auskenner habe vom Weltraum immer noch das Bild, okay, es gibt da irgendwie diese drei, vier Fernsehsatelliten, die irgendwie so Astra machen, oder wie das heißt. Dann gibt es so ein paar GPS-Satelliten, die machen, dass wir navigieren können. Da gibt es diese Raumstation. Im Großen und Ganzen war es das. Also ich stelle mir sozusagen den Orbit um die Erde, also diese Hülle quasi um die Erde, relativ dünn besiedelt vor. Ja, wie sieht es denn da oben eigentlich wirklich aus? Was ist da alles unterwegs?
Also grob ist das schon dünn besiedelt, aber es gibt halt immer wieder so Bahnen, die dann halt nicht mehr so dünn besiedelt sind. Also gerade der geostationäre Orbit, der ja irgendwie sehr ein beliebtes Ziel ist, weil man halt sich mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit wie die Erde drum herum dreht.
Okay, also geostationär, es gibt zwei verschiedene Arten, die zu bedienen. Das eine ist, der fliegt einfach immer um die Erde rum in seiner eigenen Geschwindigkeit. Und das andere ist, er versucht immer über demselben Punkt zu fliegen.
Also sie fliegen immer mit ihrer eigenen Geschwindigkeit rüber, bloß zufährweise bei einer gewissen Höhe dreht er sich halt genauso schnell um die Erde rum, wie die Erde sich um sich selber dreht.
Soll das aussehen, das würde immer im gleichen Punkt stehen, über der Erde.
Genau, und in dieser Höhe ist natürlich sozusagen viel Betrieb. Ist das jetzt wirklich so, dass da Stau ist?
Na also, auf jeden Fall, also sie meinten, sie haben noch für die nächsten paar Jahre noch genug Slots, aber da wird es auf jeden Fall eng. Also anders als in anderen Umlaufbahnen, also ob du jetzt irgendwie 200 Kilometer drüber bist oder 250 Kilometer, da spielt es halt irgendwie nicht so eine große Rolle. Allerdings, dieser geostationäre Orbit ist halt relativ begrenzt. Da muss man halt schon wirklich die Höhe halbwegs einhalten. Und wenn man das tun will, dann hat man halt auch nur gewissen Platz. Also noch dazu, wo sie halt auch wirklich in der Äquator-Richtung immer sich rumdrehen, mussten sie ja klar, weil er dreht sich auch um den Äquator rum. Von daher kann man halt auch wirklich bloß diese eine Bahn nehmen.
Also die Inklimation ist halt so Null Grad. Also das heißt, wir sind wirklich auf der Äquator-Bahn drauf. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel diese Astra-Satelliten nimmt, also Astra ist nicht nur ein Satellit, das ist ein ganzer Satelliten-Verbund. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele das gerade sind, sechs, sieben Stück oder irgendso was. Um halt die ganzen Sender abzudecken. Sie werden auch alle paar Jahre mal ausgetaut. Aber die sind in einem Abstand von paar hundert Metern nur zueinander, sodass sie halt wirklich die ganze Zeit dieselbe Fläche ausbreiten können.
Da hab ich aber was anderes gesehen. Ja, ich hab das gerade, also sie meinten so irgendwie mehrere hundert Kilometer, weil sie halt irgendwie sonst nicht mehr auseinandergehalten werden können. Also sie senden ja natürlich irgendwie auch runter. Also mir wär so, als wenn ich heute hundert Kilometer gelesen hätte. Der Abstand zwischen den einzelnen Satelliten.
Ist aber auch wenig da oben.
Ja klar.
Ja, dann hast du das andere Problem mit Entsorgung von den Dingern.
Okay, also reden wir jetzt bei die Symone kill mit der Abstand, reden wir da von den Astra-Satelliten?
Allgemein von Satelliten, die auf der geostationären Umlaufbahn sind.
Okay, also da ist schon ein bisschen Platz dazwischen. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass da quasi so. Was machen die da oben? Also wie gesagt, GPS-Satelliten haben wir, Fernsehsatelliten haben wir. Was passiert da noch?
Wetterbeobachtung, diverseste, Spionagesatelliten natürlich.
Oh ja, das macht einen großen Teil sogar aus.
Ja, Erdvermessung, also irgendwie halt Erdmagnetfeld, so die ganzen Forschungssatelliten, also da ist schon einiges unterwegs. Also alles, was du dir vorstellen kannst, was man halt sinnvoll vom Weltraum aus irgendwie beobachten kann, sowohl in die eine Richtung, also runter zu Erde, als auch in die andere Richtung von der Erde weg, gibt es halt irgendwo einen Satelliten dafür.
Was ist denn die Halbwertzeit von so einem Satelliten?
Wenige Stunden, Tage, Monate bis viele, viele Jahre.
Also wovon hängt das ab?
Kommt auf andere, wie viele Morbide sind, ob die selber vielleicht auch einen eigenen Antrieb haben, um die Lage stabil zu halten, ob sie überhaupt noch Sprit drin haben.
Also die ganzen Kommunikations- und Forschungssatelliten würde ich mal so irgendwie wenige Jahre, also so zwei bis zehn Jahre, vielleicht.
Ja, ein bisschen mehr schon teilweise auch schon. Also ich meine, so die ganzen GPS-Satelliten, die sind ja jetzt auch schon so 15, 20 Jahre im Alter.
Die werden ja auch immer wieder ausgetauscht, oder? Oder sind das immer noch die gleichen?
Bisher noch nicht.
So, jetzt habt ihr gerade gesagt, der größte Punkt ist sozusagen, sind Spionage, also Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten, nennen wir sie mal neutral-diplomatisch, da hat der Mirko angerufen aus Chemnitz. Hallo Mirko. Du hattest eine Frage zu den Satelliten.
Genau.
Oder zu Spionage aus dem Weltraum.
Bitte, stell sie jetzt.
Ich frag mich, wie Google so, dass du halbwegs so aus dem Dingsbum so meinen Platz gucken kann.
Wenn du die Frage bitte nochmal im ganzen Satz formulieren würdest, ist es nicht ganz angekommen.
Wie Google so direkt so auf mich runtergucken kann und mich so direkt so vom Haus sehen kann.
Google Maps oder Google Earth oder so, das sind ja keine Live-Bilder. Also du kannst dich jetzt nicht einfach mal rausstellen und mal winken. Oder vor allen Dingen, wenn du jetzt mal auf die Tür gehst und dann auf Google Maps draufschaust, du wirst sehen, da ist Tag und nicht Nacht. Das ist schonmal der eine Punkt. Also das sind halt Bilder, die irgendwann mal aufgenommen wurden. Du findest auch meistens unten irgendwo so auf dem Bild, da kommt drauf ein Datum, wenn das Bild aufgenommen wurde. Aber es sind keine Live-Bilder.
Also es gibt halt wirklich Erdbeobachtungssatelliten. Also es sind auch kommerzielle Dienste, wo du halt irgendwie auch sagen kannst, du bezahlst ein paar hundert Euro oder irgendwie sowas. Und dann kriegst du halt ein Bild von einem gewissen Ausschnitt von der Welt.
Wie hoch, also diese Satelliten, die halt auch dieses Google Earth machen zum Beispiel, wie hoch fliegen die denn? Ist das ja geostationäre Orbit? Wo ist der eigentlich?
Nee, die fliegen die ganze Zeit um die Erde rum. Das sind halt so die Nachkommen von den Spielonagesatelliten. Die haben meistens diesen sogenannten Low Earth Orbit. Das ist so der Orbit so ab 150 Kilometer bis 2000 Kilometer, meist irgendwo dazwischen.
Also die wollen natürlich auch möglichst weit unten fliegen, um halt möglichst große Auflösung zu haben. Also um uns dazu zu sagen, die richtig hoch aufgelösten Bilder bei Google Earth entstehen dann durch Flugzeuge. Also sie machen halt so grobe Aufnahmen durch Satelliten. Und wenn es dann richtig ins Detail gehen soll, also wenn du dich auf dem Bild bei Google Earth sehen willst, dann ist das in der Regel ein Flugzeug, was nochmal drüber geflogen ist.
Ist jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, es gibt ja z.B. Enemy Number One oder sowas, wo halt wirklich eine Satellitenbild so reinzoomen auf die Terrasse. Gibt es das schon?
Also gibt's noch nicht, wird's auch nie geben, weil du hast einfach durch die Atmosphäre, durch die Störungen halt eine gewisse minimale Auflösung, die du da hinkriegst. Liegt halt trotzdem, also liegt bei ein paar Zentimetern, aber weiter runter wirst du auch einfach mit Satelliten niemals kommen.
Die Satelliten, die fliegen auch nicht wie die Geostationären auf Äquator-Ebene, sondern die fliegen über die Pole drüber hinweg. Das heißt, du bewegst dich ja einmal im Kreis oben und unten um die Erde herum mit dem Satellit. Der fliegt auch alle 90 Minuten quasi über den gleichen Pol.
Meine Frau, woher weißt du denn, dass das so ist, das ist meine Frau.
Die Satelliten kannst du ja messen, du kannst die Signale von denen auch reinkriegen. Du kannst sie auch teilweise mit bloßem Auge sehen, dass sie entlang fliegen. Wenn ich zum Beispiel reflektiert werde von Sonnenlicht, also du siehst schon, dass da Satelliten fliegen.
Also ihr seid davon überzeugt?
Also dass du jetzt persönlich nicht wirklich überwacht werden kannst durch Satelliten, das ist tatsächlich durch die Physik begrenzt. Also es gibt halt eine gewisse Auflösung, die du maximal erreichen kannst, wenn du mit Satelliten auf die Erde guckst und die liegt im Zentimeterbereich. Das heißt, du wirst irgendwie keine Person identifizieren können. Du kannst halt schon.
Aber wenn du Zentimeterbereich sagst, dann meistern.
Also du kannst halt schon sehen, wenn er halt irgendwie aus dem Haus kommt oder mit seinem Auto wegfährt. Das sieht man halt schon, aber du kannst halt nicht sagen, das ist die und die Person. Also das ist dann halt irgendwie drei, vier Pixel breite, irgendwie ist dann der Kopf.
Ja, das ist super. Und der Satellite fliegt in 28.000, 500 Kilometer pro Stunde über dich hinweg. Das heißt, sobald du da stehst, ist er schon direkt wieder weg. Also den siehst du gar nicht mehr so schnell, die Bilder, die aufgehören.
Aber das ist doch eigentlich Schwachsinn, oder?
Nö, du wirst ja immer wieder mal Bilder von der Erde machen, vor allem, wie sich auch die Erde selbst verändert, dafür zu erinnern.
Ich empfinde es als Schwachsinn.
Was denn?
Du kannst keinen Satelliten direkt so parken. Also du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwo auf einer Stelle stehenbleiben und dort die ganze Zeit aufnehmen. Außer du bist in geostationären Orbit, aber da bist du viel zu weit weg, um saubere, ordentliche Aufnahmen machen zu können.
Also Mirko, die übergeordnete Argumentation ist, das was du glaubst, was passiert, ist physikalisch nicht möglich. Und das weiß man, weil verschiedene Wissenschaftler sich seit mehreren hundert Jahren mit Physik beschäftigen. Ich glaube an dieser Stelle beenden wir das Gespräch mit Mirko, weil sozusagen die philosophische Grundsatzfrage, ob naturwissenschaftliche Physik gilt oder nicht, können wir heute im Verlauf der Sendung leider nicht klären. Das ist bestimmt mal eine interessante Frage, aber das schaffen wir heute nicht mehr.
Doch können wir, sie gilt.
Ja gut, das sagst du jetzt so, dann würde Mirko sagen, na ja, aber woher weißt du das denn usw. Und dazu haben wir heute keine Zeit. Aber zu einem anderen Sachen, die ihr gerade gesagt habt, hat Mungs angerufen aus Bremen, 25 Jahre. Hallo, guten Abend.
Ich hatte noch kurze Frage, ob man die Restbestände, die an alten Satelliten dort rumschwirren, so weit noch hacken kann, werden die nicht irgendwie mit der Zeit ausgelenkt oder aus der Bahn geworfen, um wieder Slots freizumachen?
Nun ja. Wie formuliere ich das am besten? Also Satelliten, die ausgedient haben, waren früher, meinst du, die sind bis zum letzten Tropfen Treibstoff betrieben worden. Das heißt, die wurden auch nicht mehr aus der Bahn rausgenommen, sondern die hängen jetzt einfach da drum. Heutzutage ist mittlerweile Verpflichtung, wenn du Satelliten hochschickst, dass du zum Schluss noch genügend Treibstoff hast, um sie auf eine andere Bahn zu bringen, so einen genannten Friedhofsorbit. Aber früher hingen die dann einfach weiter auf ihre Bahn, flogen noch weiter drum rum. Wenn du Glück hattest, war irgendwann mal die Anziehungskraft der Erde so stark, oder dass das Satellit dann auch ein bisschen gebremst wurde durch die Restatmosphäre, dass dann irgendwann runtergecrashed ist. Aber die fliegen dann meist noch ein paar Jahre einfach durch die Gegend und taumeln so durch die Gegend. Und ab und zu kann man die sogar noch erreichen. Das heißt, dass du die vielleicht nicht mehr richtig steuern kannst, weil halt kein Treibstoff mehr dran ist oder auch die Kreisel ausgedient haben. Aber ab und zu sind halt in einer guten Position, um sie auch mal erreichen zu können. Jetzt muss man ein paar Jahre zurückdenken. Alte Satelliten war auch so das Thema mit der Encryption noch nicht so gut. Das heißt, Verschlüsselungen oder Verschlüssel-Signale hochzuschieben. Die ganzen Steuersignale wurden einfach so durch die Gegend geschickt. Und wenn du die Steuersignale kennst, ich möchte mal ganz einfach muten, du kommst irgendwie auf die Satelliten drauf. Ja. Die haben wir auf jeden Fall auch. Also so ein eigenes Netz aufzubauen von Satelliten. Das ist eine Idee, die wir schon vor ein paar Jahren gesponnen haben, weil wir dadurch ein eigenes schönes Netz haben, das wir nutzen können, ohne jetzt irgendwelche Leitungen auf der Erde zu haben, die ab und zu mal abgeschaltet werden oder so. Sondern wirklich ein eigenes Netz zu haben, was dann auch weiter die Version ist.
Da stecken jetzt zwei Fragen. Das eine ist zu sagen, es gibt da oben Satelliten, wo ihr vermutet, dass die gehackt werden können. Habt ihr das schon mal probiert? Hat das irgendjemand schon mal probiert? Das ist also wirklich nur eine Vermutung.
Stimmt.
Okay, es hat möglicherweise, aber ihr wisst niemand, und ihr kennt auch nicht den Freund eines Freundes, das einen Schwiegermutter, einen Hund hat, der wiederum jemanden kennt, der das möglicherweise mal ausprobiert hat.
Der Hund war's.
Okay. Und dann ist ja die andere Frage, wo ihr gesagt habt, ah, man könnte ja vielleicht sozusagen ein eigenes Netz aufbauen. Da kommen wir zurück zu dem, was wir vorhin gesagt haben, ein Smartphone in eine Rakete stecken hochschicken. Was ich mal gelesen habe irgendwo ist, dass Leute, dass man sich, also das habt ihr auch schon gesagt, man kann sich Platz in einer Rakete kaufen, dass man so ganz kleine, irgendwie so ein paar Kubikzentimeter große Sachen irgendwie in den Weltraum schicken kann.
Ja, sogenannte CubeSats, also die sind recht bekannt, vor allen Dingen im wissenschaftlichen, universitären Umfeld. CubeSats, die sind so, Satelliten muss ich vorstellen, wie ein Würfel mit einer Kantenlänge von zehn Zentimetern. Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, die zusammenzuschalten, dann kannst du vielleicht mal 30 mal 10, mal 10 Zentimeter machen. Das sind halt so kleine Satelliten, die werden meistens dann noch von den großen oder von den Raketen mit hochgebracht. Die wiegen ja auch nicht viel. Die sind dann nochmal auf so einer kleinen Vorrichtung aufgebracht. Das heißt, wenn ein großer Satellit rausgesetzt wird, da werden auch gleichzeitig noch ein paar kleine mit rausgesetzt oder vielleicht auch ein früherer Orbit schon ein bisschen rausgesetzt. Und die sind halt im wissenschaftlichen Umfeld gerne genommen, weil sie halt eine definierte Größe haben. Bestimmte Ansprüche auch schon irgendwie gestellt werden daran. Da kannst du selber deine eigene Technik reinbauen, was du auch immer damit machen möchtest. Ob du jetzt vielleicht einfach nur die Restatmosphäre messen möchtest, ob du jetzt irgendwie die Gravitationskraft da oben messen möchtest oder ob du tatsächlich einen Kommunikationssatelliten aufbauen möchtest.
Da möchte ich jetzt gerne mal hier sagen, also wie viel brauche ich denn, oder was muss ein... Ne, andersrum. Was muss ein Stück Technik können, was muss ein Stück Technik können, um als Kommunikationssatellit zu funktionieren?
Naja, du willst Signale empfangen und Signale wegsenden. Der Vorteil ist, wenn du im Weltall bist, du hast so die ganzen Probleme, die wir hier unten haben, mit Funkwellenausbreitung gar nicht. Das heißt keine Häuser im Weg, keine Bäume, kein blödes Wetter oder so. Sondern du bist dort einfach im Weltall.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja gut für den Satelliten und vielleicht für Inter-Satelliten-Kommunikation. Aber man will ja das unten dann wieder haben.
Also tatsächlich, die einfachste Variante ist nur eine große Spiegelfläche. Also die aller, aller, allerersten Satelliten waren halt wirklich große Aluballons, die sie hochgeschickt haben, die man dann von unten aus irgendwie anpeilen konnte. Und wie gesagt, mit was auch immer Laserstrahlen hochgeschossen hat, irgendwie ist es reflektiert worden, hat man unten wieder aufgefangen. Inzwischen ist es natürlich so, dass du dann halt irgendwie transziver drauf warst. Das heißt, du hast eine Empfangseinheit, also eine Antenne, eine Empfangseinheit, den Sender und nochmal eine Antenne.
Aber ist das vergleichbar mit Technik in einem Smartphone tatsächlich?
Tatsächlich mittlerweile schon oder sogar noch einfacher. Ich meine, zum Beispiel vor ein paar Monaten, ich glaube letzten Winter war das gewesen, hat ein Japaner ein Satellit fertiggebaut, der einfach nur eine LED drauf hatte, eine ganz starke. Okay, da hat er auch noch ein Funk-Relay drauf, das heißt, man konnte die LED einschalten damit. Und da hatte die Idee gehabt, einfach mit der LED irgendwie was an den Himmel zu schreiben. Das heißt, die LED immer wieder ein- und auszuschalten, Morsezeichen zu machen, sodass du halt so ein blinkendes Objekt einfach mal da oben hast. Das hat auch funktioniert, also das ist so eine ganz einfache Komplikationsform, ja. Ansonsten gibt es schon seit Ewigkeiten, also Ewigkeiten, also in diesem Fall seit Anfang der 60er Jahre Amateurfunksatelliten.
Heißt?
Die heißen Oscar. Das ist von den Amateurfunken, also die sich ja selber sehr viel mit Funktechnik auseinandersetzen. Die haben dann schon kleine Satelliten gebaut, das sind auch wirklich nicht große Teile, die Signale empfangen können und die auch wieder Signale aussenden können. Sogenannte Relaisstationen, die gibt es wirklich schon lange. Jetzt gehen auch mal noch einige unterwegs dort oben, die fliegen auch manchmal ein paar Jahre sogar. Die kannst du dann halt auch sehr einfach mit Antenne trecken. Das ist, was vielleicht noch einfacher geht, ist die ISS zu nehmen. Die ISS, die sieht man ja auch ab und zu mal so am lichtlichen Himmel sehr gut, als leuchtenden, also wirklich ganz hellen Leuchtendenpunkt, der über uns hinweg fliegt. Mit einer recht moderaten Geschwindigkeit auch noch. Also gut, die 28.000 km pro Stunde, die sie fliegt. Nehmen wir halt für vier bis fünf Minuten, nehmen wir die wahr. Dann fliegt die so halt über den Himmel hinweg. Und wenn du damals so eine Antenne draufhältst und ein Funkgerät hast oder einen Fänger hast, der auf 145, 8 MHz läuft, dann kannst du teilweise sogar einfach das empfangen, was darüber gesendet wird. Und teilweise sind es einfach auch nur andere Funkamateure, die Signale hochsenden und einfach mal so ein Hallo rausrufen. Die kannst du auch darüber empfangen. Und das ist recht einfach zu trecken, weil du diesen hellen Punkt einfach siehst.
Aber senden die über diese Frequenz auch was? Also kann man sich da mit den Leuten unterhalten? Oder kann man nur hören, was die aussenden oder was läuft?
Ne, du kannst selber auch hochsenden. Das ist eine andere Frequenz dann. Man hat es ein bisschen schwierig gemacht, damit nichts einfach hochkommt. Es ist eine andere Frequenz, sie ist aber auch frei verfügbar. Es ist eine andere Frequenzband einfach. Da braucht man schon ein bisschen mehr Power dafür, um da hoch zu kommen. Aber es klappt auch. Teilweise kannst du dich auch mit den Astronauten, Kosmonauten, die auf der ISS sind, auch unterhalten. Also die sind auch alles Funkamateure. Und manchmal haben die da mal irgendwie in ihrer vielen langen Freizeit auf der Raumstation auch Bock, sich ans Funkrader anzusetzen. Und dann kannst du auch mit denen reden.
Also es gab die Story von der, auf der Mir war das, glaube ich, wo das Feuer war? War das mir? Ja, mir war das. Also wir hatten heute ein Feuer oben gehabt. Irgendwie haben dann irgendwie alle Panik geschoben, irgendwie das Feuer gelöscht und haben dann natürlich nach unten, wir hatten hier ein Feuer. Und es war halt irgendwie Mitte der Nacht. Das heißt, die Bodenstationen waren, glaube ich, im Funkschatten gewesen. Und dann haben sie halt einfach mit so Funkamateuren, haben es halt so als erste die Funkamateure mitgekriegt, dass sie da oben gerade ein Feuer hatten. Und dann irgendwie in der Zentralstation angerufen, meinten, ihr hattet da ein Feuer oben.
Das ist auch geil, wo die dann so, hä, ja, ja, erzählst du, du hast mit so Leuten geredet. Aber noch mal zurück zu den Satelliten. Also sagen, für unser eigenes kleines Internet würden wir wahrscheinlich so eine Art kleinen Rechner haben wollen.
Also die Rechentechnik ist halt tatsächlich irgendwie nichts super modernes mehr. Also ich meine, ein Telefon ist auf jeden Fall mehr drin, als du brauchst, um da oben Satelliten zu benutzen. Ich glaube, von der Antennentechnik her ist es schon noch ein bisschen größerer aufhand. Also da kannst du nicht einfach die Antenne vom Telefon nehmen. Aber irgendwie jetzt nichts, was man halt irgendwie... Also ich meine, es ist auch im Zweifelsfall nur eine Schüssel, die da irgendwie dann ran...
So ein WLAN-Router wäre zum Beispiel superklasse einfach. So ein WLAN-Router hochzuschicken, der drin hängt, die Technik davon. Du würdest sogar die WLAN-Signale dann hier unten auf der Erde noch empfangen können.
Das muss ich erzählen, mal ein bisschen genauer erklären. Weil der Punkt ist, bei mir in der Wohnung habe ich das Problem, in der Küche WLAN zu haben, wenn das Ding hinter der Wand ist. Wenn das Ding hinter der Wand ist. Ja gut, aber ich stelle mir jetzt vor, zu sagen, so eine Wand ist trotzdem kein Problem als 150 Kilometer.
Doch, ist genau das Problem.
Echt?
Ja.
Also es ist halt eine Frage der Frequenz und diese 2, 4 Gigahertz oder 5 Gigahertz, wo das WLAN heutzutage üblicherweise drauf sendet, geht halt nicht besonders gut durch Wände durch. Allerdings in der freien Umgebung hast du sehr gute Ausbreitungsbedingungen.
So lange es regnet, ja.
Genau, wenn du halt auf der Erde... Also es gibt halt so Long-Range-Senderempfangs-Contests, wo sie halt auf jeden Fall mehrere, also zig Kilometer gemacht haben, auf der Erde selber drauf. Und wenn der Satellit oben rumfliegt und du nach oben schießen kannst und jetzt nicht gerade ganz viele Wolken mit Wasser drüber sind, dann kannst du da sehr well...
Der Nachteil ist natürlich, dass der Satellit so schnell ist, dass der halt nur für 3, 4, 5 Minuten zu sehen ist. Und dann brauchst du wieder 90 Minuten, bis er wieder da ist.
Du musst halt die Antenne mit nachführen und halt z.B. zwei Genusssatelliten haben, die du nachher anstrecken kannst.
Und den Dopplereffekt ausgleichen, das ist noch das andere Problem. Aber grundsätzlich gesehen, das sind lösbare Probleme, die es vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit deinem normalen PC... Ja, doch, mit deinem normalen PC. Könntest du das eigentlich auch machen? Doch, das geht. Doch, Donate, das sind lösbare Probleme, die kennen wir auch heutzutage alle, weiß man auch, wie man damit umgeht. Und ich denke, das ist tatsächlich in der Zukunft möglich, so ein kleines Netz halt aufzubauen, so ein Komplikationsnetz.
Also ich entnehme den Sachen, die ihr erzählt zu sagen, dass es im Prinzip schon möglich wäre, aber momentan noch zu großer Aufriss ist, um es wirklich selber zu machen.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, die Kosten, das hochzubringen, das ist irgendwie der einzige Hindernisfaktor dabei.
Was hätte man da für einen Vorteil, wenn man da so ein Netz von kleinen Satelliten mit eigener Technik, also was könntet ihr, was habt ihr für Ideen, die man da möglicherweise dort oben...
Würdest du mir mehr einkaufen wollen, wenn ich sage, hey, ich hab ein schnüffelfreies Netz da oben, das kannst du immer nutzen. Ist das für dich interessant genug?
Möglicherweise wäre das eine Idee, aber ist das tatsächlich realistisch? Ich stelle mir schon vor, man schießt halt irgendwie Netz hoch und dann geht es auch irgendwie, aber wäre das wirklich, also wäre wirklich denkbar, dass man ein Satelliten-Internet baut, das sozusagen schnell genug ist, um es wirklich zu benutzen? Oder ist das dann eher sozusagen, das ist dann nochmal ein Extranetz, da geht es dann zu sagen, da kann man nur per Text kommunizieren, weil die Bandbreite zu gering ist und sowas. Oder ist das wirklich so, da kann man so richtig was bauen?
Komm drauf an, was du wirklich machen willst. Bandbreiten? Ja, also... Ich guck grad mal den Leon an, der kennt sich da besser mit aus. Das haben wir mitgenommen.
Das Problem am Satelliteninternet ist vor allem, also in den letzten Jahren auch weniger, die Bandbreite tatsächlich. Also man kann sich das sogar kaufen mittlerweile von kommerziellen Anbietern. Und dann kann man da irgendwie tatsächlich auch hochladen mit vernünftiger Geschwindigkeit und auch runterladen. Das Problem ist, dass das einzelne Paket sehr lange braucht. Das heißt, man hat eine hohe Latenz, ehe ein Paket da ist. Aber man kann viele Gläste hier unterwegs haben, aber bis einzelne da ist, dauert es. Das heißt, der Ping ist schlecht. Das verstehen Gamer aber schon ganz gut. Man muss auch ein bisschen warten, ehe seine Seite aufgerufen wäre zum Beispiel.
Okay, also sowas wie mailen und surfen ginge noch?
Genau, das ging ja ganz gut.
Du kannst kein Counter Strike mehr zocken.
Ja, und das aber überwachungsfrei quasi. Solange da nicht jemand hochgeht und meinen Satelliten aufschraubt. Wie weit sind wir da?
Das ist tatsächlich, also auf jeden Fall in der Theorie oder in der anfänglichen Praxis auch schon, sind sie dabei. Also es gibt schon Überlegungen oder tatsächlich auch schon Satelliten, die halt andere Satelliten greifen können. Also es geht halt darum, entweder zur Reparatur bzw. die Idee ist tatsächlich, wenn wir vorhin von Weltraumschrott geredet haben, dass es halt Satelliten gibt, die sich halt so langsam an ein Stück Weltraumschraub ranmanivrieren und es dann anstoßen, dass es halt irgendwie Richtung Erde wegglüstet und dann verglüht. Und natürlich kann man sich auch vorstellen, dass wenn man halt erst mal so einen Satelliten hat, der sich dann halt wirklich auch an einen fremden Kommunikationssatelliten andockt und dann mit seinen Greifärmchen die Kabel umsteckt.
Wie habt ihr erzählt, diese 10 Kubikzentimeter Dinger, die sind ja auch standardisiert. Da weiß man ja, wo die Öffnung ist.
Also braucht man auch so einen kleinen Standard halt einfach. Dem macht es günstiger, die Dinger hochzustecken auf jeden Fall.
Haben wir noch was vergessen, was die Satelliten angeht?
Bestimmt. Ich hatte vorhin irgendwie was, weil es um Überwachung mit Satelliten gab. Ein interessanter Faktum ist das Hubble-Zeloskop. Das ist mal kaputt gewesen und sie sind dann irgendwann dazu übergegangen, einen von der NSA, also einem Geheimdienst benutzten Pendant, was ebenfalls oben war, was aber nicht in den Weltraum geguckt hat, sondern auf die Erde geguckt hat. Das heißt, es gab tatsächlich ein identisches Hubble-2, was nach unten geguckt hat als Überwachungs-Satellit, den sie dann irgendwann, weil sie es nicht mehr gebraucht haben, auch sagt, sie brauchen das nicht mehr. Das heißt, sie haben inzwischen schon ausreichend gute Ersatz dafür gefunden, was sie dann halt einfach umgedreht haben und damit dann in den Weltraum gucken konnten.
Was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, es kamen häufiger diese 90 Minuten jetzt. Also eine Erdumrunde in 90 Minuten. Und wir haben ja angefangen mit dem Film Gravity, wo ja auch genau das eine Rolle spielt. Alle 90 Minuten kommt diese Weltraum-Schrott-Volt wieder rum. Jetzt habt ihr schon erzählt, okay, also Satelliten irgendwie sind so hunderte von Kilometern auseinander. Ist denn diese Weltraum-Schrott-Wolke in diesem Film realistisch?
Ja, das ist durchaus realistisch. Das ist tatsächlich ein Bedrohungsszenario, was wir haben. Dieser ganze Weltraum-Schrott, der da rumfliegt. Vor allen Dingen, wenn so ein Stück getroffen wird. Also wenn so ein Satellit getroffen wird von irgendwie kleinen Kometen.
Oder von den Chinesen. Es gab tatsächlich den Fall, dass die Chinesen irgendwie ganz groß angekündigt haben, wir können jetzt auch Satelliten abschießen. Und sie haben es tatsächlich auch gemacht. Woraufhin dann irgendwie alle die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen haben und sagten, ihr seid hier bescheuert, weil sie halt einfach mal einen Satelliten zerstört haben, der sich in Millionen von Teilen oder Tausende von Teilen zersplittert hat.
Die dann noch mal selber noch eine zusätzliche Geschwindigkeit drauf kriegen zu diesen 28.000 Kilometer pro Stunde, die dann noch ein bisschen schneller durch die Gegend fliegen und dann kommen die wieder an andere Satelliten dran und hauen diese Satelliten kaputt, die dann auch wieder kaputt gehen.
Dass das Problem ist, wenn es halt irgendwie ein großes Stück ist, dann fliegt es halt schön mit seinen 28.000 Kilometer pro Stunde irgendwie um die Erde rum. In einem Stück. Sobald es aber irgendwie kaputt geht, dann hast du den Effekt, dass du halt in diverse Richtungen, das wegdriftet, sich total wild durch die Gegend drehst und dann im Zweifelsfall nochmal gegen ein anderes Stück stößt und dann halt total unkontrolliert in alle Richtungen.
Das ist mal so eine Person namens Kessler, die dann auch ausgerechnet hat, dass wir in ein paar zig Jahren, ich hab jetzt die genaue Zahl nicht in den Kopf, aber auf jeden Fall werden wir weiter so machen mit unserem Weltraumschrott, irgendwann gar nicht mehr von der Erde wegkommen können, weil wir einfach so viel Schrott um uns herum gelagert haben, dass wir nicht mehr zerstören oder unfallfrei wegkommen, bis zum Mond hin oder noch weiter weg, sondern dass wirklich so viel Zeug so einfach rumliegt, das sogenannte Kessler-Effekt auch nach ihm benannt.
Also ist es auch so, dass die ISS zum Beispiel in regelmäßigen Abständen mal Bahnkorrekturen durchführen muss, weil halt einfach da grad so ein Stück Schrott durch die Gegend fliegt, in dem sie halt ausweichen muss.
Also dieses Szenario, was da in dem Film so aufgerufen wird, nämlich irgendjemand schießt einen Satelliten ab?
Ja, es war nicht nur ein Satellit, es war, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab im Film, war das eine ausgebrannte Stufe. Also eine Raketenstufe. Ich meine, das ist auch das eine Problem mit Raketenstufen, die halt hochbringen, die Feststoffbooster, die wir dran haben, oder die erste Stufe, die fliegt meist noch irgendwie zurück auf die Erde. Aber die weiteren Stufen, die hinten dran sind, die werden halt im Orbit irgendwo abgeschossen. Und die wandern nur ganz, ganz langsam wieder zurück. Und die meisten Objekte, die wir als Satelliten draußen sehen können, das sind tatsächlich ausgebrannte Stufen, die teilweise schon seit 50 Jahren herumwabern.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall realistisch, umso schlimmer, je öfter sie von irgendwelchen anderen Teilen getroffen werden und dann kleiner werden und noch kleiner werden. Und dann hat das hier wirklich Wolken von Schrott.
Und die Wolken bleiben dann auch zusammen. Weil ich dachte erst sagen, wenn ich so ein Ding schieße, dann platzert es ja in andere Richtungen.
Dieser Kessler-Effekt, dass du halt dann in diverse Richtungen, also jedes Mal, wenn es halt wieder getroffen wird, hast du eine andere Drehrichtung und eine andere Beschwindigung in irgendeine Richtung.
Und es ist trotzdem so eine Wolke von Müll, die sozusagen in einem Orbit dann wiederum um die Erde fliegt.
Die bleibt im ähnlichen Orbit, außer sie wandert wirklich dann so weit raus, weil du halt ein bisschen mehr Geschwindigkeit drauf gekriegt hast, dass sie dann halt auf einen anderen Orbit draufkommt. Ich meine, das sind dann so Orbitalmanöver. Also wenn du schneller bist, dann wird der Orbit größer. Wenn du langsamer, also wenn du in Bremsrichtung halt irgendwie fliegst, dann wird es ein kleiner Orbit. Das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Okay, gut. Wir halten fest, es gibt Müll. Und es ist interessant, Satelliten hochzuschicken, weil dann könnten wir unser eigenes abhörsichtiges Internet machen.
Gut.
Dann, wenn wir jetzt die Technik in den Weltraum geschossen haben, reden wir gleich darüber, was man mit den Kohlenstoffformen, den lebendigen da oben machen kann. Kurz Pause, dann sind wir gleich wieder da. Chaos Radio heute im Blue Moon. Es geht um den Weltraum und da hören wir jetzt den Song von jemand, der total wichtig ist dafür, dass Weltraum und Raumschifffahrt in den letzten Monaten, Jahren so ein bisschen an Begeisterung gewonnen hat. Space Oddity, im Original von David Bowie, hier performt und auch ein bisschen umgetextet von Commander Hadfield, ein Astronaut der ISS. Das erste im Weltraum gedrehte Video ist auch dazu entstanden. Und warum hört ihr das heute hier? Weil wir heute hier im Chaos Radio Implomun über Raumfahrt und den Weltraum reden. Wir haben schon geklärt, wie man dort hochkommt. Wir haben schon geklärt, was man mit den Satelliten dort anstellen kann. Und wir wollen von euch auch wissen, was ihr davon haltet, dass es dieses ganze Weltraum Ding überhaupt gibt. Also soll man das machen? Soll man da Millionen von Euro hin verschwenden? Findet ihr das interessant? Würdet ihr gerne mal dorthin. Oder möchtet ihr gerne mal selber was dorthin schicken? 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer, unter der ihr hier mitmachen könnt. Zu Gast im Studio sind Starbuck, Leon und Lars. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Ach so, ich müsste vielleicht auch mein Mikrofon aufmachen. Sehr gut. Und wir wollen uns jetzt damit beschäftigen, wie man da einen Menschen hochkriegt. Wie kriegt man einen Menschen hoch? Also mal abgesehen davon, dass man ihn da hochschießt. Was sind so die grundlegenden Probleme, die man klären musste, bevor das überhaupt funktioniert hat?
Naja, ich meine grundlegende Probleme sind ja, hier auf der Erde hast du ja im Grunde das, was du zum Leben brauchst grundsätzlich. Also Sauerstoff. Kaffee auch. Nee, aber Sauerstoff ist halt so die einige Sache. Wasser findest du ja auch fast überall, aus so ein bisschen verdörrten Gebieten, klar. Aber so ganz grob gesehen, diese Erde ist schon mal gar nicht mal so schlecht, um hier drauf leben zu können. Im Weltall muss ich den ganzen Krempel mit mir schleppen. Das heißt, ich muss meinen Sauerstoff mit mir herum schleppen. Ich muss halt noch irgendwas mit mir schleppen, was mich vor den Strahlen schützt. Da haben wir hier so ein tolles Erdmagnetfeld in nördlichen und südlichen Gebieten. Da leuchtet es manchmal auch ganz toll so, wenn so die ganzen lustigen Strahlen drauf raufprassen, diese Polarlichter.
Eine Heizung nicht zu vergessen.
Eine Heizung, ja, genau. Also so im Weltall kannst du mal warm, mal kalt werden, kommt drauf an, auf welche Seite des Planeten du gerade bist.
Also das ist eh ein ziemlich großes Problem allgemein, wenn man halt so Sachen in den Weltraum schickt, also auch so deine kleinen Satelliten, dass du halt an der Sonnenzugewandtenseite so Temperaturen von plus 150 Grad hast und auf der abgewandten Seite bist du bei minus 350. Also auf jeden Fall extrem große Unterschiede irgendwie. Und das führt natürlich auch zu Spannungen in deinen Geräten und so weiter.
Aber du musst tatsächlich den ganzen Kram mit dir führen. Du musst die ganze Schurzausrüstung mit dir führen und du hast nicht so viel Gewicht, wie wir vorhin schon mal gehört hatten. Also so fünf Tonnen kann ich da mal so hochbringen im Material. Da musst du echt schon aufpassen, was du mitbringst. Also kannst du jetzt nicht einfach mal so halbe Spanferkel mit einstecken, um es dann halt mal schön in den Böcker verputzen, sondern du brauchst halt auch diese herrliche Astronautennahrung dazu.
Also die ist nicht nur ein Tuben, weil es in der Schwerelosigkeit einfacher zu essen ist, sondern auch, weil die einfach dann leichter so transportiert ist, wenn man sie zusammenquetscht.
Ja, und auch gebüttelt halt einfach, ja.
Ist es denn so, dass die Strahlung eigentlich das wirklich lebensgefährliche im Weltraum ist?
Auch. Also Strahlung ist natürlich eins der ganz großen Probleme. Andere kleine Objekte, die noch rumfliegen, die oft nicht drauf passen können. Das Vakuum bzw. die Luftlehre ist natürlich das Problem halt. Zeit brauche ich einen ordentlichen Raumanzug, um da rausgehen zu können. Und ja Strahlung, also Wärme und Kälte ist ja ein Grunde auch Strahlung ist passend.
Was das Vakuum angeht, man stellt sich ja mal vor, die, also ich habe mir das lange vorgestellt, ich habe auch von Leuten gehört, dass das immer noch ihre Vorstellung ist. Der Raumanzug geht auf und peng platzt der Mensch, weil Vakuum, aber das stimmt ja gar nicht, habe ich gehört. Man kann bis zu einer Minute im Weltraum überleben.
Habe ich auch gehört. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal ausprobiert wurde. Ich hoffe, es passiert auch nicht.
Ich meine, irgendwo gelesen zu haben, dass es mittlerweile genug Notfälle mit Raumanzügen gab, als dass man das als gesicherte Erkenntnis anbietet.
Ne, platzen wird es wohl nicht sein. Die ersten Vorstellungen waren so, wir kennen es vielleicht aus der Schule noch, diesen schönen Versuch, wir stellen so ein Glas mit Wasser unter eine Käseglocke und machen dann mal ein Vakuum drin. Wenn man fängt, das Wasser anzubrodeln, hat man sich auch gedacht, wenn so ein Mensch einfach rausgeht im Weltraum ohne Anzug, dann wird das Blut direkt anfangen zu kochen. Nee, wird wohl nicht so sein, sondern die Haut schützt schon sehr, sehr gut.
Aber das ist doch ein ähnliches Problem, wie wenn du als Tiefseeltaucher zu schnell auftauchst, dass der Druckunterschied dich dein Blut zum Kochen bringt. Das sollte doch da oben dann ähnlich sein.
Wird ähnlich sein, aber soweit ich weiß, ich hab auch so was gehört mit 1-2 Minuten, dass du auch mal im Vakuum quasi ein bisschen überleben kannst, aber du bist halt sehr, sehr schnell kaputt. Also Sauerstoffunterbindung oder Sauerstoffzufuhr zum Gehirn, die ist halt sehr schnell eingestellt.
Das ist doch mal eine Frage an die Hörer.
Haben wir Ärzte unter uns, die schon mal im Weltraum Patienten mit Schwerelosigkeit...
Also hier Weltraummediziner oder Leute, die genau wissen, was da passiert.
Jetzt, hallo.
0331 70 97 110.
So und wo wir gerade bei Leben im Weltraum sind, hat der Martin auch gleich angerufen. Hallo Martin aus Reinickendorf. Hallo, wo möchtest du gerne im Weltraum leben?
Ich hab jetzt nicht zugehört, weil ich das Radio ausgemacht habe, aber im Weltraum möchte ich erst mal nicht leben. Vielleicht mit dem Anzug, aber sonst wär's schwierig.
Was ist deine Frage?
Meine Frage? Ich hab vielleicht eine Anmerkung. Also ich interessiere mich auch für das Thema Raumfahrt und was damit zusammenhängt Astrophysik und Astronomie. Und insbesondere finde ich das Thema Exoplaneten sehr faszinierend. Und mittlerweile hat man ja um die 1000 Exoplaneten entdeckt. Das wären ja quasi wöchentlich mehr.
Martin, die Regel beim Chaosradio ist, wer zuerst ein Fremdwort benutzt, muss es auch erklären. Was ist ein Exoplanet für jeden, der es noch nie gehört hat?
Ein Exoplanet ist ein Planet, der sich nicht in unserem Sonnensystem befindet, sondern einem Sonnensystem außerhalb, einer einen fremden Sonnensystem sozusagen, wie der Name schon Exo sagt. Also ein Planet, der um einen fremden Stern kreist. Und wie gesagt, man hat mittlerweile um die 1000 entdeckt und es wären quasi wöchentlich mehr, insbesondere durch die Daten von Kepler. Mittlerweile hat er leider nicht mehr funktioniert. Und ja, leider, was ich schade finde, wir haben zwar schon so viele Exoplaneten entdeckt, aber die Informationen, die wir über sie haben, sind doch sehr dürftig. Ja, wir kennen vielleicht die Masse.
Sind aber auch ganz schön weit weg.
Das stimmt, ja. Wir kennen die Masse, den Orbit, vielleicht die Temperatur. Von einigen wenigen kommt vielleicht auch das Spektrum, das Spektrum, das direkte Sonnenlicht einfangen und einige Elemente in die Atmosphäre nachweisen. Aber was man sich ja so wünschen würde, wäre vielleicht so Bilder von Exoplaneten, wie man sie vielleicht von der Erde kennt. Dass man Meere sieht, Wolken, vielleicht irgendwelche unnatürlichen Strukturen auf der Oberfläche. Und das war halt so ein Gedanke, der mich mal beschäftigt hat. Und die Frage an euch wäre, denkt ihr, dass sowas überhaupt physikalisch möglich ist? Also dass man quasi einen Exoplaneten vielleicht in 10, 20 Lichtjahren Entfernung so auflösen kann, dass man solche Informationen hier rekonstruieren könnte?
Du sagst es schon, also 10, 20 Lichtjahre Entfernung. Lichtjahr ist tatsächlich eine Entfernung, das ist die Strecke, die das Licht braucht, um innerhalb eines Jahres sich zurückzulegen. Das heißt, die Planeten, die wir dort jetzt gerade sehen, also die wir halt durch irgendwelche Spektrometer mal gefunden haben, das ist alles Licht, was irgendwie dort so vor 10, 20 Jahren mal an den Planeten vorbeigestrahlt ist. Das ist also schon sehr, sehr lange her.
Das ist ja egal. Ich meine, du musst ja einfach mal die Größenordnung vor Augen halten. Also ich meine, versuch's einfach mal auf der Erde runterzubrechen, zum Beispiel in der Vergrößerung vom Mikroskop. Und dann, wenn du halt diese 10, 20 Lichtjahre in eine Entfernung umrechnest, dann wird dir klar werden, dass das irgendwie einfach mal nicht machbar sei. Also ich meine, wenn du mal...
Ich muss zugeben, das war eine Fangfrage.
Ja klar, das ist schwierig.
Ich hab diese Frage interessanterweise auch mal... Ich hatte mal die Gelegenheit, mit diesem Astrophysiker Harald Dech zu sprechen. Und ich hab ihm dieselbe Frage gestellt. Und der meinte zu mir auch, das ist eigentlich nicht möglich. Das ist aber auch schon Jahre her, das glaub ich, vor 10 Jahren oder länger.
Das wird doch einfach niemals möglich sein.
Ja, das ist der Punkt, da möchte ich aber widersprechen. Denn ich hab was sehr Interessantes gelesen. Und zwar, ihr kennt sicher den Effekt der Gravitationslinse.
Ja, das wollte ich gerade drauf, wollte ich gerade hinaus.
Und wir haben eine, also jede Masse erzeugt ja, kommt ihr raus. Und da gibt es eine entsprechende Gravitationslinse. Im Prinzip haben wir eine solche Gravitationslinse direkt in unserem Sonnensystem. Und zwar erzeugt durch die Sonne. Aus der Jupiter erzeugt eine so große, aber die Sonne aus.
Jetzt wird es aber schon sehr, sehr technisch.
Ich wollte gerade mal sagen, Martin, halt, einen Moment. Eine Gravitationslinse, ich fürchte fast, das ist nicht erklärbar. Kann man in einfachen Worten zusammenfassen, was das sein soll?
Eine Lupe.
Eine Lupe, ja, das kann man vielleicht so sagen. Eine Lupe, die aber erzeugt wird durch die Masse eines Objekts.
Also der Licht, das Licht wird ja auch durch Massen irgendwie abgelenkt. Und du kannst natürlich, also wenn du halt ein Objekt beobachtest, was hinter der Sonne ist, wird natürlich das Licht, was von diesem Objekt ausgesendet wird, durch die Sonne auch gebeugt. Das heißt, wenn du halt genau in diesem Beugungspunkt, also in diesem Brennpunkt der Sonne dann bist, dann siehst du natürlich die Sachen, also wie auch wirklich von der Linse. Wenn du die irgendwie in die Sonne hältst, dann ist ja dahinter irgendwie auch ein Brennpunkt, wo dann halt irgendwie das Papier anfängt zu kokelen. Aber trotzdem, also selbst mit irgendwie der Sonne als Gravitationslinse würden sie halt niemals Bilder hinkriegen, die halt einen Planeten als Planeten darstellen, dass du Wolken drauf siehst. Das ist halt...
Meiner Meinung nach ist diese Information nicht korrekt.
Du könntest...
Ja, ich glaube, da können wir jetzt sehr lange auch darüber diskutieren, aber die Frage ist jetzt, wie können wir jetzt gerade von einem benommten Raumfahrtsintervallus zu uns kommen?
Vielleicht kann ich noch was sagen, wenn das erlaubt ist.
Bitte.
Und zwar gibt es wirklich ein reelles Konzept, welches auch theoretisch berechnet wurde. Es gibt das Konzept, einen Geschwader aus kleinen Spiegeln genau im Bremspunkt der Gravitations- und der Sonne zu positionieren und dann per Interferometrie quasi einen riesigen Spiegel zu erzeugen. Und man hat wirklich ausgerechnet, dass es möglich wäre, damit in 10 bis 20 Lichtjahre Entfernung solch hohe Auflösungen zu erreichen, dass man wirklich diese Details wie Kontinenten der Meere abbilden könnte. Das ist ein französischer Astrophysiker, der ausgerechnet hat. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie der heißt.
Hast du eine Quelle?
Telepolis. Telepolis vor halbem Jahr, glaube ich, fand ich drin. Ich kann den Link mal raussuchen.
Such doch den Link mal raus. Wir haben doch bestimmt eine Mail-Adresse, oder? Chaosradio, etc. etc.
Genau, Chaosradio, etc.
Also das ist tatsächlich theoretisch durchaus möglich.
Also ich könnte es mir mit mehreren Gravitationslitsen durchaus vorstellen, die man halt dann irgendwie aber erzeugen muss oder bzw. durch Zufall zwar praktisch zwei Sterne im richtigen, in der richtigen, also in einer Linie praktisch. Mit einer Gravitationslitsen, so ein Spiegeln, würde ich behaupten nicht, aber ich meine, wenn du was gelesen hast und das fundiert ist...
Ich würde mir die Hand auch dafür abschneiden, aber wie gesagt, das ist ja keine Stimme.
Such doch mal die Quelle raus, schick doch mal an Chaosradio. Das würde mich auf jeden Fall interessieren auch.
Ja, bitte.
Und wir gehen jetzt zurück zur bemannten Raumfahrt. Normalerweise muss ich die Leute, die hier vom Chaos Computer Club da sind, im Zaum halten, damit sie nicht kompliziert werden. Jetzt macht ihr das schon da draußen. Ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie der Letzte, der irgendwie...
Ich finde das total super.
Ich finde das auch total super.
Das ist total spannendes Thema, aber Weltraum ist groß und hat auch sehr viele Themen.
Bewandte Raumfahrt. So, gibt es Probleme? Haben wir gesagt, also wurden gelöst? Wie kommen wir denn jetzt selber dahin? Ist das überhaupt realistisch?
Also du meinst, du und ich jetzt hier, dass wir jetzt so quasi, anstatt jetzt irgendwo ins Auto zu steigen und gleich zurück zu fahren, dass wir einfach sagen, hey, komm, lass uns mal unsere Rakete nehmen und zu unserer Raumstation zurück zu fliegen, ne?
Ja, ja.
Wär schön, ne?
Wär ich dabei.
Aber wie kommen wir selbst dahin? Momentan ist es leider nur wenige Leute vorbehalten, halt mal in den Weltall zu fliegen. Entweder weil du technisch halt einiges drauf hast.
Oder weil du viel Geld hast.
Oder weil du viel Geld hast. Ich sag, das sind so die zwei Faktoren, um in den Weltraum reinzukommen. Das ist ja, also so dieses, ich geh jetzt mal morgen dahin und kauf mir ein Ticket ins All. Ich glaube, das passiert jetzt auch noch nicht so schnell. Es gibt zwar Anfänge, in diese Richtung halt reinzuarbeiten. Jetzt nicht nur durch senkrecht startende Raketen, sondern auch durch Flugzeuge, die schnell genug sind, die auch so die Weltanlinie, also die 100 Kilometer auch ankratzen können.
Es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die das irgendwie durchgerechnet haben und irgendwie so sagen, in absehbarer Zeit von 10 bis 15 Jahren wird es möglich sein für, sagen wir, ja, wenige Zehntausende Euros halt für ein paar Tage oder ein paar Stunden auf einem Hotel im Weltraum irgendwie kurzzeitig zu richten.
Das habe ich vor 10 bis 15 Jahren auch schon gehört. Also merken wir sind nicht so weit gekommen.
Naja, aber immerhin ist doch Richard Garriott zum Beispiel, also so jemand, der mit Spielcomputer spielt.
Oder Mark Schuttelwürstel hat es auch gemacht, hat sich auch mal eingekauft.
Aber die waren ja auch noch auf der ISS, oder?
Ja, genau, richtig. Die sind zur ISS geflogen.
Aber das gab es schon, dass Leute, dass Privatpersonen für Geld im Weltraum waren.
Das waren jetzt sechs, sieben Leute, die es gemacht haben. Das war noch zur Zeit noch, als noch die Shuttles zusätzlich geflogen sind, also das Space Shuttle. Das heißt, da hatten dann die Russen selber noch ein bisschen Platz gehabt ab und zu mal und haben noch mal ein, ihre drei Plätze in der Soyuz-Rakete mal für jemanden freigemacht, der genügend Geld auf den Tisch gelegt hat und damit auch das Programm ein bisschen mit unterstützt hat. Mittlerweile wird es nicht mehr gemacht, weil wirklich die Soyuz nur so die einzige, momentan das einzige bemannte Raumschiff oder bemannbare Raumschiff ist, was wir in den Weltraum schicken können. Das Shuttle ist eingestellt worden. Alle anderen Dinger sind halt, naja, Quatsch, Chinesen kommen ja jetzt auch noch. Ha, genau, die haben wir jetzt noch.
Aber es reduziert sich tatsächlich irgendwie auf den Faktor oder auf den Fakt, dass du halt nicht genug Raketen, Starts auf die Reihe kriegst, um halt irgendwie genug Leute hochzubringen. Wenn man halt wieder, was vorhin schon angesprochen wurde, den Space Elevator hat, wo du halt wirklich dann einen Aufzug hast, wo du unten einsteigst irgendwie und nach ein paar Stunden oder ein paar Tagen dann irgendwie oben aussteigst, dann sind das auch keine Kosten mehr und dann ist es natürlich irgendwie auch durchaus bezahlbar, einfach mal kurzzeitig in den Weltraum hoch zu rufen. Hoch zu steigen und wieder runterzukommen.
Aber das ist tatsächlich noch Zukunftsmusik.
Das ist noch Zukunftsmusik, aber da würde ich durchaus sagen, das kann man, also können wir in unserem Alter durchaus noch erleben.
Ja, im Alter.
So, jetzt, warum eigentlich, dass man Satelliten hochschickt, das finde ich total verständlich, weil man sagt, alles klar, die sind dann da oben und machen uns Sachen leichter, also die Signalübertragung ist viel besser, wir können Weltraum reingucken usw. Aber warum soll es schickt man Menschen in den Weltraum? Also ich meine, okay, es ist geil und man hat es halt mal gemacht, aber...
Na, irgendwer muss die Experimente da oben auch bedienen können.
Roboter?
Die waren zu der Zeit, als die ersten Menschen im Weltraum waren, noch gar nicht so weit. Ja, mittlerweile auch nicht wirklich. Also die Roboter-Technik ist auch nicht so weit fortgeschritten, die muss halt auch bedient werden. Und so ein Mensch ist halt einfach immer noch das optimale Objekt und schnell Entscheidungen auch durchführen zu können, auch mal neue Sachen zu machen. Also das heißt, dieser Hacking-Effekt im Grunde dabei ist. Also was wir ja auch ständig mit unseren Computern machen. Das machen Astronauten, Kosmonauten, Raumfahrer generell auch ständig.
Also ich glaube, das ist einfach...
Technik anders nutzen, als sie eigentlich geplant war.
Einen Blick in die etwas fernere Zukunft. Natürlich wird die Menschheit nicht ewig auf dem Planeten Erde wohnen wollen können. Also wenn sie sich nicht vorher ausrottet, gibt es irgendwann den Punkt, wo sie sagen, wir sind zu viele, wir wollen mal woanders hin oder wir haben keine Ressourcen mehr. Dafür ist die Forschung, die sie derzeit auf den Raumstationen machen, die Grundlage. Also erst mal zu gucken, wie kommt der Mensch klar im Weltraum mit Schwerelosigkeit oder mit geringen Versorgungsmöglichkeiten. Gab es zum Beispiel auch in den USA in den 80ern Biosphäre das Experiment, wo sich halt eine gewisse Anzahl von Leuten in ein hermetisch abgeschlossenes Gewächshaus eingeschlossen haben mit so und so viel Quadratmeter Pflanzen und Wasser und irgendwie Tieren und Recycling. Und halt einfach auch da mal geguckt haben, ist es denn möglich, Menschen über einen langen Zeitraum überhaupt am Leben zu erhalten, außerhalb der normalen Erdumgebung.
Ich meine, das war mit Mars 500 ja jetzt auch schon gemacht worden. Also sprich diese Mission, dass man einfach ein paar Leute 500 Tage eingeschlossen hat und eine Mars-Mission simuliert hatte.
Genau, das ist natürlich dann der nächste Schritt nach der Mondlandung, natürlich halt wirklich dann Menschen auch zum Mars zu bringen. Das dauert halt eine Weile.
Gibt es da nicht irgendwie so eine Casting-Show mittlerweile schon?
Casting-Show?
Ja, da war neulich irgendwas, dass es irgendwie so ein Programm gibt, da kann man sich bewerben und dann werden halt irgendwann zum Schluss ein paar Leute ausgewählt und dorthin geschickt. Die können dann auch nicht mehr zurückkommen.
Ja, es gab da so ein Ding auch. So ein One Way Ticket finde ich einfach mal nicht so prickelnd, ganz ehrlich. Ich finde es echt cooler, irgendwie Leute hinzuschicken zu Mond, Mars, wo auch immer hin und auch wieder halt zurückzubringen. Also das ist das höchste Ziel tatsächlich.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall spannend. Du würdest jetzt sagen, wenn du die Wahl kriegst, pass auf, hier Mars geht klar, kannst du aber nicht zurück, würdest du nicht machen?
Würde ich nicht machen. Ich weiß, dass es genügend Menschen gibt, die sagen so cool, ich will mal zu Mars und ich nehme ein One Way Ticket, aber kann ich ganz ehrlich ethisch nicht vereinbaren mit mir.
Mars ist noch Zukunftsmusik, du hast dich auch genauer belesen über das, was die Leute, die auf der ISS, also der Internationalen Space Station sind, den ganzen Tag so treiben und wie man sich da ein Burrito basteln kann.
Das fand ich ganz lustig, Commander Hetfield, den wir gerade schon mal singen gehört hatten, hat dann auch irgendwann mal, oder ich mein, der Mensch war großartig, der war ja ein bisschen mehr als ein halbes Jahr auf der ISS gewesen und der hat so viel dafür getan, dass dieses Thema Weltraum wieder interessant wurde. Ich meine, viele haben vielleicht seine Bilder gesehen irgendwie, die er vor allen Dingen per Twitter halt rumgeschickt hatte. Sehr tolle, grandiose Aufnahmen von der Erde. Er hat teilweise ein paar Videos gemacht, ein paar Experimente auch gemacht. Und ich mein, die Raumfahrer haben sehr viel Zeit noch neben ihrem normalen Arbeitsprogramm halt und können auch wirklich mal Spürkis auch betreiben.
Wie ist das ungefähr auch geteilt?
Die haben also von, man versucht einen 24-Stunden-Rhythmus auch zu halten dort oben. Ich meine, hey, du fliegst alle 90 Minuten um die Erde rum. Das heißt, Moment, wie oft ist das dann? 16 Mal am Tag oder so kreist du halt um die Erde rum.
Und hast deinen Aufgang und Untergang.
Ja, das ist toll, 16 Mal am Tag Sonnenoffen und Untergang zu haben. Ja, aber man versucht tatsächlich einen 24-Stunden-Rhythmus zu halten. Dieser ist so aufgeteilt, dass eigentlich in der Regel nur 6 Stunden Arbeitszeit sind. Davon sind auch schon anderthalb Stunden für das Muskelaufbautraining oder Muskelerhaltungstraining halt mit eingeplant. Das heißt, du hast quasi 18 Stunden Freizeit, also so 7-8 Stunden Schlaf solltest du haben, sind irgendwie 2-3 Stunden für Essen auch mit eingeplant. Ansonsten hast du so im Grunde Freizeit, was halt ein bisschen da oben vertreiben kannst. Und es gibt halt einige... Einige Raumfahrer, die halt auch dort oben sind, die dann auch für private, interessante Sachen halt auch offen sind. Und ich hab auch so ein nettes Video gesehen, wo... Ich hätte mal wieder ein Burrito essen. Und sind halt Leute hingegangen und haben geguckt, was habt ihr denn an Essen dort oben auf der ISS gerade da? Habt sich einfach mal alles ausgebreitet und haben dann mal so ein Rezept hochgeschickt. So, ja, dann nimmst du jetzt einfach mal hier von diesem klein gehäckselten Schnitzel irgendwie eine Packung. Dann nimmst du noch von da drüben irgendwie ein paar Maiskolben, bzw. Dann gibts auch irgendwo ein spezielles Brot, ein recht dünnes, und da kannst du dir irgendwas zusammenbasteln und irgendwo hast du auch eine Chili-Sauce da rumstehen. Es ist einfach total großartig, wieder versucht, so ein Burrito im Weltall zusammenzubarmen und zu futtern, weil halt dummerweise die Hälfte des Burritos irgendwann mal durch die Kasse oder durch die ISS geflogen ist.
In dem Film Gravity, da holt ja dann George Clooney irgendwann die Vodka-Flasche aus einem Sitz hervor.
Ja, unterm Sitz, also wissen wir noch immer, die Vodka-Flasche liegt unterm Fahrersitz. Dürfen die saufen im Weltraum? Da gibt es unterschiedliche Meinungen zu. Es gibt wohl durchaus kleine Alkoholreserven auch in der ISS und wohl auch kleine Reserven an Vodka natürlich, die dann auch entsprechend von unseren russischen Kosmonauten mit hochgebracht wurden, die wohl auch nicht darauf verzichten möchten. Ab und zu mal so ein bisschen Vodka zu haben. Nee, kannst du im Weltraum auch trinken, das geht. Ist bisher noch nicht irgendwie negativ aufgefallen, aber du solltest halt auch irgendwie bei deinem Sinn bleiben. Klar, wildes Säufnis im Weltall ist, glaube ich, nicht ganz so doll.
Gibt es auch was, was ich auch spannend finde, da leben dann halt irgendwie so zwei, drei Leute. Drei ist, glaube ich, die maximale Anzahl oder eine ISS?
Ne, also sechs ist die Standardbesatzung, also zwei Teams, drei Personen. Teilweise waren auch mehr dort, aber die waren dann halt durchs Shuttle angedockt. Also das heißt, es waren auch schon durchaus, warte mal, das war recht, ein Shuttle, sieben Leute plus sechs Leute, da sind wir dann halt irgendwie so bei 13 Personen, die dann halt irgendwie auch um sind.
Okay, aber sagen sechs Leute, die ständig da sind, gibt es da auch irgendwelche Erkenntnisse von wegen der Psychologie? Das stelle ich mir schon spannend, vor auf so engen Raum.
Also tatsächlich bei den ESA-Einstellungstests ist es ein ganz, ganz großer Punkt, dass es Menschen sind, die auch miteinander umgehen können. Also die jetzt wirklich so ein ruhiger Typus sind, auch einen kühlen Kopf die ganze Zeit behalten können, aber auch nicht zu so einem großen Eco-Trip fahren. Also das ist ein ganz großer Punkt, um halt dort mit bei zu sein. Weil du kannst nicht die ganze Truppe halt irgendwie untergraben von der Moral her.
Und du bekommst in der Ausbildung ganz viel kulturelle Sensitivität beigebracht. Und auch die Kontrollstrukturen haben sich über die Jahre, also da hat man sehr viel gelernt über die Jahre, wie man mit Astronauten umgeht vom Bodenzentrum aus. Denn letztendlich ist man die ganze Zeit dabei, denen Befehle zu geben den ganzen Tag. Und wenn man das nicht verträgt, bzw. wenn man das nicht sensibel macht, dann kann das auch schiefgehen. Es gab zum Beispiel mal auf der Mir ein Vorfall tatsächlich, dass die Astronauten gestreikt haben, nachdem sie einfach überlastet wurden vom Kontrollzentrum. Das haben die nicht eingesehen.
Wie sah das aus? Wie komm ich mehr runter?
Ja, ne, wir machen jetzt halt nicht mehr, was sie sagen. Und das ist halt ein Problem, wenn die da oben sind, dann irgendwie auf sich alleine gestellt sind und eine teure Technik in der Hand haben und man sich nicht einfach mal auf ein Vier-Augengespräch mit dem Chef treffen kann. Ja, und seitdem ist auch viel mehr auf die Tagesordnung gekommen, dass man darauf Rücksicht nimmt, wie es den Astronauten gerade geht und ab und zu immer persönliche Wort redet und mehr Kontakt mit der Familie zulässt.
Das heißt, auch da anscheinend korrekt recherchiert, das ist ja bei Gravity zu sehen, dass die so einen seltsamen Mischmasch haben. Also einerseits sprechen sie sich die ganze Zeit in so offiziellen Formeln an, also dieses Copy und Bestätigung, aber andererseits geht es auch so um dieses persönliche Ding, da erzählt immer einer so Geschichten und die scherzen auch auf eine sehr abstrakte Art und Weise miteinander. Das ist dann auch wahrscheinlich etwas, was wirklich so funktioniert.
Also wenn du selber mal die Streams von der ISS anschaust, auch vor allen Dingen wenn die mal so Spacewalks machen, du kriegst ja komplett alles mit, also siehst, was die draußen gerade machen. Eine Kamera, Helmkamera nimmt das auf, oder halt eine Kamera aus dem Cockpit nimmt das halt auf, also von der ISS selber halt. Du hörst auch den Ton dabei. Also was halt mit der Erde gesprochen wird, mit dem sogenannten Capcom, mit dem Ansprechpartner auf der Erde gesprochen wird, ist auch immer nur eine Person auf der Erde. Das wechsel ich ständig durch, um halt wirklich diese Vertrautheit zu behalten. Kelly auch, ist auch meist ein ausgebildeter Astronaut. Und halt untereinander, dass sie auch dann ein bisschen rumscherzen und so. Das kriegen die hin, weil du brauchst es wirklich, um im Moral zu auch zu erhalten. Das ist halt spannend.
Würdet ihr da hin, für ein halbes Jahr?
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich noch in den Weltraum kommen werde. Das hört sich aber spannend an.
Ich hätte echt mal Bock. Würdet ihr alle machen?
Ein halbes Jahr wäre mir viel zu lang. Ich glaube, da würde ich durchdrehen.
Aber so ein Urlaubstrip irgendwie, statt Ostsee, mal zwei Wochen ISS.
Alles klar, wenn ihr günstige Angebote habt, könnt ihr euch gerne melden, 03717097110. Wir sprechen gleich noch mal eine halbe Stunde über alles andere, was wir vergessen haben. Zum Beispiel ist noch ein spannender Punkt, dass der Weltraumfahrt lange, lange, lange Startensache war und immer weiter privatisiert wird. Da müssen wir auch gleich noch mal drüber sprechen. Vorher gibt es aber die Nachrichten. Sobald ich diese Musik hier ausgemacht habe.
Und zwar jetzt.
Dazu eine große Portion Swing. Eine noch größere Portion knusprige Elektro-Beans. Und dann das Ganze schön live hochkochen. Mittwoch, 11. Dezember, Parov Stella live in der Arena.
Präsentiert von Fritz. Der frühere US-Geheimdienstmitarbeiter Snowden ist offenbar bereit, vor einem Untersuchungsausschuss des Bundestages zur Spionage-Affäre auszusagen. Das sagte der Grünen-Bundesabgeordnete Ströbele dem ARD-Magazin Panorama. Ströbele hat Snowden in seinem russischen Exil getroffen. Das dreistündige Treffen mit dem Ex-NSA-Mitarbeiter habe unter strengster Geheimhaltung stattgefunden, hieß es weiter. Die USA suchen Snowden mit Haftbefehl und werfen ihm Landesverrat vor. Der US-Geheimdienst NSA überwacht offenbar noch mehr deutsche Spitzenpolitiker als bisher bekannt. Die New York Times berichtet, dass die NSA nicht nur das Handy von Bundeskanzlerin Merkel überwacht hat, sondern auch die Telefone von ranghohen Beamten und den Chefs der Oppositionsparteien. An den Späheraktionen soll nach weiteren Medienberichten auch die US-Botschaft in Berlin beteiligt sein, mithilfe von Spionageanlagen auf dem Dach des Hauses am Pariser Platz. Botschafter Amazon wies die Vorwürfe im RBB zurück.
Kein Alkoholverkauf mehr am Abend.
Das fordert ein Netzwerk von elf deutschen Großstädten. Darunter ist auch Potsdam. Die Städte meinen, dass es mehr Jugendkriminalität und Komasaufen gibt, weil Jugendliche spät abends noch Alkohol kaufen können. Das Netzwerk forderte die Bundesregierung auf, den Verkauf zeitlich einzuschränken. Außerdem müsse stärker kontrolliert werden, ob Supermärkte, Spätis und Tankstellen Alkohol an unter 18-Jährige verkaufen. In einem Asylbewerberheim in Brandenburgischen Henningsdorf hat es gebrannt. Die Polizei ermittelt wegen schwerer Brandstiftung gegen einen 18-jährigen Bewohner des Heims. Er soll Möbel angezündet haben. Warum ist noch unklar? Die Feuerwehr konnte den Brand schnell löschen. Die Flüchtlingsunterkunft musste eine Stunde lang geräumt werden. Ein Polizist erlitt eine Rauchvergiftung. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin und Brandenburg liegen zwischen 0 und 7 Grad. Heute Nacht dichte Wolken, etwas Regen. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 6 bis um die 0 Grad runter. Morgenvormittag gibt es nur in der Lausitz ein bisschen Sonnenschein. Danach wird es aber auch da, wie sonst überall in Berlin und Brandenburg, bewölkt. Und es kann auch immer mal regnen bei maximal 13 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Charlottenburg, Richard-Wagner-Straße. Die ist zwischen Richard-Wagner-Platz und Bismarckstraße in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Auch beide Fahrtrichtungen sind dicht bis 4 Uhr früh. Altklinik Wegedonstraße zwischen Semmelweisstraße und Rudower Straße ist wegen Arbeiten an Gasleitungen gesperrt. Zum Verkehr in Brandenburg, A13, Dresden Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Lübbener und Duben sind in beiden Richtungen Tiere auf der Fahrbahn. Fahr dort bitte besonders vorsichtig. Und A24, Hamburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Mayenburg und Pritzwalk ist nach einem Lasterunfall voll gesperrt. Also Hamburg Richtung Berlin. Das dauert da wohl noch mindestens zwei Stunden. Letzte freie Ausfahrt ist Mayenburg. Und noch mal zur Berliner S-Bahn. Für die S2 fahren zwischen Marienfelde und Priesterweg bis zum 8. November weiterhin Busse. Bis Betriebsschluss fahren auch auf der S1 zwischen Birkenwerder und Oranienburg ersatzweise Busse. Und zum RE1 zwischen Berlin-Osparnow und Erkner fahren bis zum 4.
November Busse.
Ihr könnt auf die S-Bahn-Linie 3 ausweichen. Kommt gut durch die Nacht.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit man.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch am Chaos Radio hier im Blue Moon, wo wir uns heute im Weltraum befinden und endlich weiten. Naja, ganz so ganz und endlich sind sie noch nicht. Wir haben festgestellt, es ist noch alles ein bisschen schwierig mit dem Weltraum. Aber immerhin, wir kommen schon in den Erdorbit. Also bis da hoch. Raketen, Satelliten, Menschen haben wir alle schon dahingebracht. Und jetzt kümmern wir uns quasi um den Rest. Die erste Frage, die ich da habe an die Herren Starbuck, Leon und Lars, die heute hier sind und uns mit in den Weltraum leben, es gab einmal eine Mondlandung und seitdem ist nichts mehr passiert.
Warum? Es waren ja fünf Landungen. Mit Leuten? Ja, sechs Landungen sogar.
Auch total geil.
Also zwölf verschiedene Menschen waren auf dem Mond, keine Frau, alles Männer.
Ganz ehrlich Leute, wer von euch hat das gewusst?
Aber ich hab das auch lange nicht gewusst.
Eine Mondlandung ist nicht geglückt. Also es sollten eigentlich sieben gewesen sein, eigentlich waren noch ein paar mehr geplant, die sind aber hinter eingestellt worden, weil das wurde auf einmal uninteressant.
Warum?
Selbst die Bevölkerung hat sich gar nicht mehr dafür interessiert. Also die erste Mondlandung war noch super im Medienecho und so die zweite, naja. Und bei der dritten hat man auch tatsächlich im Fernsehen das gar nicht mehr live übertragen. Es wurde erst wieder mit Apollo 13 interessant. Also das war ja eigentlich die dritte gewesen, aber wäre gewesen, aber es wurde erst damit wieder interessant, dass sie halt nicht gelandet sind auf dem Mond. Aber später hat man dann gesagt, so ja komm, jetzt haben wir genügend Mondgestein eingesammelt. Wir haben genügend Messungen durchgeführt. Das ganze Programm ist sau teuer. Lass uns das mal einstellen. Das war 1972, glaube ich.
Aber da hab ich zum Beispiel die Frage, ist es teurer, eine Mission, also ein halbes Jahr auf dem Mond zu leben, als ein halbes Jahr in der ISS?
Ja. Warum? Du musst auf den Mond das ganze Zeug jetzt mal hinbringen.
Ja, aber du musst nicht die ganze Zeit rumfliegen und hast eine Oberfläche auf der...
Fliegen tut's ja von alleine.
Und irgendwie, ja.
Du musst es halt irgendwie nur einmal hochbringen. Weil im Mond ist es so, dass du es dann auch nochmal runterbringen musst. Das heißt, du musst dann irgendwie auch nochmal deutlich mehr Treibstoff mit hochnehmen, um halt auch sauber zu landen.
Also Wärme, Kälte ist noch ein anderes Problem. Der Mond hat ja eine bunne Rotation mit der Erde. Wir sehen ja nur eine Seite vom Mond. Das heißt, wenn wir Vollmond haben, dann wird diese Seite komplett angestrahlt. Und wenn wir Neumond haben, dann liegt die halt so im Schatten drin. Das heißt, du hast so zwei Wochen Helligkeit, zwei Wochen Dunkelheit. Und das kommt halt auch nicht so deutlich. Man heizt sich dann zwei Wochen lang alles so mal schön auf. Und es ist zwei Wochen sehr kalt. Also du musst halt wirklich sehr viel dran machen.
Besser als wenn das weg schon alle paar Stunden wäre.
Ja, das passt auch für ISS gerade.
Ja, und dann ist der Mond auch einfach noch viel weiter als ISS.
Das stimmt auch mal wieder.
Die Raketen, die man braucht, um zum Mond zu kommen, die hat man ja beim Apollo-Programm gesehen. Die waren irgendwie so russienhoch aus. Und das ist halt schon ein ganz anderer Gewissen, auch dann so ein Programm durchzuführen.
Also ich glaube tatsächlich vom Leben dort, also wenn erst mal alles da wäre, wäre es auf jeden Fall einfacher. Ich meine, du hast auch ein bisschen Schwerkraft und so was. Hast in Zweifel auch ein bisschen Wasser. Aber halt erst mal hinkommen ist halt das große Problem. Deswegen schon wieder Space Elevator. Man kann natürlich irgendwie nicht nur einen bauen, der um die Erde rumkreist, sondern auch den, der um den Mond rumkreist. Das heißt, die würden sich dann auch schon fast berühren. Das heißt, man würde dann sich nur noch also oben von dem Erdelevator irgendwie abstoßen, kurz ein bisschen rüber schweben, dort irgendwie wieder runterfahren.
Dann hängst du einfach noch einfach einen am Lagrange-Punkt auf und dann ist der Punkt halt zwischen Mond und Erde, wo sich die Kräfte gegenseitig aufheben, also wo du die richtige schwere Losigkeit hast. Ansonsten hast du immer so schwere Losigkeit irgendwie zu der einen Richtung oder zur anderen Richtung hin.
Wie lange muss das Kabel sein für den?
Du hilfst dann den deostationären Orbit aufhängen.
Also du hast halt nach unten 36.000 Kilometer, nach oben, weil halt irgendwie die Schwerkraft weniger.
36.000 Kilometer.
Also das Kabel selber wäre dann ungefähr so was wie 70.000-80.000 Kilometer. Also es geht halt nicht mit normalen Hanfseil. Die Idee, die sie gerade haben, ist natürlich Kohlenstoffnanneröhrchen, die von der Festigkeit halt schon ungefähr das haben, was man braucht. Da ist halt bisher das Problem, dass sie sie halt einfach nicht in der ausreichenden Länge machen und da reden wir halt nicht von irgendwie, naja sie schaffen halt ein paar Kilometer, sondern sie sind halt irgendwie bei ein paar Millimetern inzwischen. Aber wie gesagt, also das kann durchaus sein, dass dann wie ein Chinese morgen kommt und sagt, ich hab eine tolle neue Technik gefunden und wir müssen nur ein bisschen Zirrettenasche irgendwie in die Verbrennungskammer schicken und dann kommt das lange Kabel raus. Also das würde ich tatsächlich sagen, das ist auf jeden Fall in absehbarer Zeit durchaus in der Möglichkeit der Realisation.
Jetzt ist es ja so, also Mond ist irgendwie zu teuer, deswegen nicht mehr gemacht, die Leute interessieren sich nicht mehr dafür. Jetzt ist es die USA haben ihr Shuttle Programm eingestellt und da sind jetzt sozusagen private Leute, die da reingehen. Normalerweise wird es so mit Misstrauen beobachtet, wenn so Privatfirmen Dinge übernehmen, die eigentlich in der öffentlichen Hand liegen. Wie ist das bei der Raumfahrt?
Ja, ist auch schon ein bisschen länger so. Und ich meine, private Firmen gab es immer wieder, die ein bisschen raumfahrtisch gemacht haben. Aber in diesem Fall geht es wirklich darum, dass gesagt wurde, die NASA macht jetzt nicht mehr die ganzen Flüge zur Versorgung der ISS. Das heißt, es wurden andere Firmen oder es wurden generell Firmen aufgerufen, selber Raumschiffe oder Raketen überhaupt erst mal zu entwickeln. Und da ist vor allen Dingen eine Firma ganz stark hervorgekommen, die Firma SpaceX, die sich auch erst 2002 gegründet haben. Und die haben mittlerweile drei, vier Raketen gebaut, die auch fliegen können. Und die sind irgendwie total stark dahinter, so diese Rocket Sign zu betreiben. Die haben nach sieben Jahren oder sieben Jahren nach der Gründung ihre erste Rakete hochgeschickt, die Falcon One. Das ist wirklich so einfach eine Rakete mit einem Motor dran, also mit einem Verbrennungsausgang hinten dran. Die haben sie erst mal hochgeschickt bzw. auch das Ganze erst mal getestet. Mittlerweile sind die so weit, dass die halt die sogenannte Falcon Nine haben. Die Nine oder Neun halt kommt dadurch, dass sie sieben, äh, Quatsch, neun. Dadurch, dass sie halt neun Raketenausgänge hinten dran haben, die jetzt so ja entweder als Würfel oder halt auch als Kreisland angeordnet sind. Es sind noch kleine Unterschiede noch dabei. Diese Falcon Nine ist mittlerweile auch so ein Transportschiff geworden, womit eine Kapsel, die sogenannte Dragon Capsule, zu ISS gebracht wird. Das ist momentan ein Versorgungsraumschiff, um mal so ein bisschen Wasser wieder hochzubringen, ein bisschen Futter hochzubringen, Sauerstoff vor allen Dingen auch wieder mit hochzubringen. Andere Experimente, die halt interessant sind, auch mit auf die ISS rüber zu transportieren.
Weil man da Sauerstoff hochbringen muss, warum gibt es da eigentlich noch nicht so eine Art, keine Ahnung, selbst erhaltenes oder selbst versorgendes Raumschiff? Kann man das nicht irgendwie machen?
Also die Biosphären-Modell, von dem Starbuck vorhin schon mal gesprochen hatte, ja, das geht in diese Richtung rein, aber es ist noch nicht so ausgereift, dass es komplett hält. Ich meine, es wird schon sehr viel recycelt, also der komplette Sauerstoff wird auch wieder aufbearbeitet, dass du den dann noch mal atmen kannst. Auch das Wasser wird wieder aufbearbeitet. Also bei Wasser sprechen wir nicht nur deine verdauerten Getränke, sondern wir sprechen auch von dem Schweiß, der durch die Klimaanlage wieder eingesammelt wird, aufbereitet wird. Also das ist auch das, was dahinter auch wieder getrunken wird durchaus. Du musst schon ein bisschen hart sein, solltest nicht so stark drüber nachdenken, was du dort zu dir nimmst, aber es geht halt einfach nicht anders.
Krass. Aber zu sagen, ist da die ISS auch noch zu klein für so ein Biosphären-Ding? Weil es braucht wahrscheinlich auch eine bestimmte Größe.
Also es wird natürlich versucht, es sind auch Experimente auf der ISS drauf, wo auch mit organischen Materialien, also Pflanzen vor allen Dingen, gearbeitet wird, dass da auch mal der eine oder andere Salatkopf angebaut wird. Das sieht eigentlich ganz lustig aus, weil die wachsen alle Richtungen quasi. Du hast im Grunde eine Röhre mit einem Substrat drauf und darauf sind die Salatköpfe gepflanzt, die dann so nach oben und unten quasi wachsen rundherum.
Ein Salatball. Um auch noch mal zurück zu den Hackerdingern zu kommen, du hast noch geschrieben in der Vorbereitung, dass Hacker oder Hack-Sachen auch Zulieferer für Weltraumtechnik sein können.
Also es sind halt interessante Sachen dabei. Vor allen Dingen, wenn wir wieder auf Kommunikation gehen, sind ja immer wieder Experimente gemacht worden, um auch Geräte anzuschließen, dass sie miteinander kommunizieren können. So Freifunk ist ja so ein Thema. Wir kennen es teilweise aus Berlin. Da gibt es ja diese ganzen WLAN-Netze, diese Freifunk-Netzwerke, wo jeder mit jedem im Grunde reden kann. Und das ist ja eine interessante Sache für das Satellitennetz, sodass auch die Satelliten untereinander kommunizieren können, sodass sich von einem Punkt der Erde über drei, vier, fünf, acht Satelliten halt ein Signal weiterreichen kann, um an anderen Punkten der Erde wieder runter zu kommen.
Aber das ist ja momentan auch nicht so, oder? Dass im Weltraum alle miteinander zusammenarbeiten? Gibt es da zumindest die...
Schön wär's.
Wie ist denn die Situation?
Sehr viel Konkurrenz natürlich dort und auch sehr viel Heimhaltung teilweise dabei. Wäre schöner, wenn dort viele einfach mehr miteinander reden würden, auch viele mehr miteinander was bauen würden, um ganzes Großes zu erstellen. Aber ich glaube, dann sind wieder zu viele Köche dran und das kennen wir ja, dass sie einen Beil verdärmen.
Wer ist denn da alles unterwegs? Also was ich jetzt weiß, ich dachte auch, es gibt nur eine Mondanlage, also die USA sind da, die Russen sind da und die haben beide noch so Europäer mit dem Schlepptau. Die Chinesen? Wie weit sind die? Also das hat mich überrascht. Im Film Gravity gibt es eine chinesische Space Station.
Ja, die gibt es ja jetzt schon. Ja, es gibt eine Space Station, die, wie heißt die jetzt gleich? Die Tiangong Station. Ich habe wahrscheinlich das falsch ausgesprochen, aber mein Ungarnschinese ist nicht so gut.
Und mit Zopf hast du wahrscheinlich gerade gesagt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich irgendwie. Es gibt eine Raumstation, die vor zwei Jahren hochgebracht wurde. Also es ist im Grunde ein Modul, was dort nur herumschwebt, was auch nicht ständig besetzt ist. Und die Chinesen haben ein Raumschiff schon gebaut. Das Shenzhou heißt das, glaube ich, Raumschiff. Sieht im Grunde aus wie eine Soyuz. Ich meine, irgendwo haben sie die Baupläne halt gekriegt. Der Osten arbeitet zusammen. Ist aber ein bisschen größer gebaut worden. Also in der normalen Soyuz war ursprünglich nur Platz für zwei Personen, jetzt ist Platz für drei und die Shenzhou-Fähre ist halt für vier Personen ausgelegt. Und die haben jetzt auch vor kurzem dafür Aufregung gesorgt, dass sie auf einmal dann mal so ein paar Personen hochgeschickt haben und auf diese Raumstation auch drauf, die vorher hochgebracht wurde, mal für ein paar Tage besetzt haben. Das ist aber die erste Inkarnation dieser Raumstation. Die wird auch 2014 versenkt werden, also einmal so ab in die Atmosphäre rein und verglühen und runterkleiden lassen, ähnlich wie man die Bier halt auch versenkt hatte vor ein paar Jahren.
Warum macht man das eigentlich? Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt schon enorme Kosten hat, um dieses ganze Metall da irgendwie hochzubringen, warum versucht man das nicht oben zu lassen und dann später daraus was schickes zu bauen?
Und wurde auch erst mal gedacht, dass man die Bier auch weiterverwendet, aber die war halt einfach zu veraltet?
Na, es geht jetzt gar nicht so sehr um die tatsächlich Weiternutzung, sondern einfach nur, dass das Rohmaterial, also ich meine, man hat einfach irgendwie Metall da hochgebracht, was halt irgendwie durchaus ja sinnvoll wäre, wenn man das da oben hat, das irgendwie dann zu versuchen, weiterzubenutzen für etwas anderes.
Also ich denke mal, es liegt nicht daran, dieses Material auseinanderzunehmen und wieder zusammenzusetzen, dass einfach zu viel Energie aufwenden würde. Ich meine, du kannst auf so einem Spacewalk außerhalb deiner Schützen- und Raumstation kannst auch dich nicht so viel bewegen. Also die brauchen, um so ein blödes Hubble-Teleskop mal zu reparieren, um da mal Solarpaneele auszutauschen und ein paar kleine Computerteile auszutauschen. Fünf Spacewalks mit zwei Personen, 7 Stunden. Das ist schon mal nicht ohne. Also du schaffst wirklich wenig in deiner Zeit, die du da draußen bist, weil du unheimlich langsam nur arbeiten kannst. Du kannst dich ja nicht richtig bewegen im ganzen Anzug, den du dabei hast.
Da muss man halt wieder Roboter nehmen.
Ja, muss man Roboter nehmen. Also ich glaube, es ist wirklich schwierig. Es ist einfacher, was Neues hochzuschicken, als jetzt die alte Technik zu nehmen. Vor allem bei der Mir war es ja so gewesen, die war ziemlich verbeult, dadurch, dass ja irgendwann mal ein Progress-Schiff falsch angedockt hatte. Oder versucht hat, er falsch anzudocken. Ein Modul ist kaputt gewesen, also es ist wirklich sehr stark verbeult, konnte nicht mal verwendet werden. War dummer, weil das erste amerikanische Modul, was mit angedockt wurde.
So ein Zufall.
Und ja, das Ding hat man echt dann versenkt hinterher. Ich meine, es war auch ein Feuer auf der Mir schon drauf gewesen. Die Technik war halt einfach noch nicht ausgegriffen. Aber es war eine super tolle Raumstation, um viele Erfahrungen zu sammeln. Und das erste Modul der ISS ist auch baugleich mit dem ersten Modul der Mir gewesen. Also es ist ein sehr baugleiches Modul gewesen, tatsächlich.
Wir waren gerade dabei, dass die Chinesen dann ihr die erste...
Ah, whoops, schon wieder das baugleiche Modul. Sehr, sehr, sehr ähnlich.
Was Gutes gebaut. Aber das soll irgendwann versenkt werden.
Scheint eine Markengreize zu werden. Also, macht einen Schlager zu werden. Nee, aber das soll versenkt werden. Die wollen ein zweites noch mal hochschicken, um weitere Tests durchzuführen. Und die dritte Station soll dann auch ausgebaut werden, also mehrere Module zusammenkoppeln. Zufälligerweise soll die dritte Station im Jahre 2020 fertig werden. Das ist das Jahr, wo momentan die ISS ihre Auslaufzeit hat. Also die wird ja auch nur für ein paar Jahre weiter begrenzt von den Zeiten her. Und momentan liegt Finanzierung vor bis 2020. Was danach passiert ist momentan auch unklar. Kann natürlich sein, dass verlängert wird, weil gesagt wird, ey, komm, wir haben gerade diese Station da, lass sie mal ein bisschen weiter betreiben. Oder ob eine Kooperation mit den Chinesen eingegangen wird, die sich auch mittlerweile schon ein bisschen kooperationsbereit erklärt haben. Das ist alles ein bisschen fraglich. Müssen wir noch schauen, wo es darauf hinauslaufen wird. Aber irgendeine Station, so wie es momentan aussieht, werden wir wohl weiterhin im Weltall haben, was ich auch ziemlich cool finde.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche Länder, die Raumfahrt machen?
Indien macht Raumfahrt. Brazilien kann mittlerweile auch Raketen starten.
Die Japaner?
Japan, ja, eigene Raketen ein bisschen auch. Aber die hängen halt auch mit der ISS zusammen. Also die haben da auch Module mit hochgebracht. Also sie sind eher auch in der Kooperation mit da drin, anstatt dass sie jetzt ihren Ego-Trip machen und eigene Raketen hoch schicken.
Und wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit immer wieder geguckt. Gravity, war das so irgendwie alles okay? Und das klingt alles, als hätten die das sehr, sehr, sehr korrekt gemacht. Was mich wundert, weil auf mich wirkt es immer so, weil ich einen Film gesehen habe. Na ja, das sieht schon irgendwie okay aus, aber wird bestimmt ausgedacht sein. Kann man generell sagen, dass das, was sie dir zeigen, wirklich gut ist?
Vieles. Also viele einzelne Sequenzen sind echt gut gemacht. Was ein bisschen daneben ist und was auch der Regisseur selber sagt, so ja, da hab ich ein bisschen Fantasie walten lassen, ist diese Entfernung. Ich meine, am Anfang fühlen sie es halt, ja, die sind in der 600 Kilometer Höhe, wo das Hubble halt auch ausgesetzt wurde. Und kommen innerhalb kürzester Zeit wieder in den Orbit rein. Also es sind ja im Grunde, ich glaube, zwei Umkreisungen von diesen kleinen Teilen, sprich 180 Minuten später, sind die wieder im Orbit dran. Und eine Raumstation, also wie es diese chinesische Raumstation direkt im Orbit auszusetzen macht man auch nicht. Die hängen halt auch auf 300 Kilometer in Höhe. Aber auch vom Hubble bis zur ISS ist ein Unterschied von 300 Kilometern beispielsweise. Von der Höhe her so ganz klar. Wobei ISS hängt so 350 bis 400 Kilometer. Also 250 Kilometer Entfernung.
Das heißt, es wäre viel länger gedauert da hinzukommen?
Zum einen das. Und vor allen Dingen kannst du auch nicht geradeaus einfach mal fliegen. Wenn du auf ein Objekt zuhältst, änderst du dein Orbit und das orbitale Manöver ist halt was ganz anderes als hier auf der Erde durch die Gegend zu fahren. Ist sehr sehr komplex, aber wenn es einer verstanden hat, den geht es ganz gut.
Okay, schaffen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr.
So, ne schaffen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr. Also das sind halt so die kleineren Fehler als diese Übergangssequenzen, sag ich mal in dem Film. Aber grundsätzlich gesehen ist der sehr viele Punkte, sind ja sehr realistisch drin. Also ob es jetzt eine Kerze ist oder ein Feuer, was halt einfach nur als Kugelball durch die Gegend warbart und sowas, ist super toll gemacht. Also das hat mich beeindruckt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Okay, Gravity also, er hat sich quasi dramatische Feinheiten rausgenommen, aber funktioniert. Es gibt noch eine andere Sache, die ich fragen muss, wo wir jetzt schon zwei Stunden über Weltraum geredet haben. Warum hat der Chaos Computer Club vor allen seinen größeren Veranstaltungen eine Rakete rumzustehen?
Na ja, eine Rakete ohne Motor, ne?
Das macht doch erst recht keinen Sinn.
Die Rakete, diese kleine, die man da immer so rumstehen sieht, was heißt klein, die ist ja auch 7 Meter hoch, ist die sogenannte Fairy Dust. Das ist ein Tochter Schiff von der Heart of Gold. Heart of Gold ist das Schiff aus dem Anhalter durch die Galaxis. Das Buch von Douglas Adams. Es gab auch mal ein Hörspiel und ein Film dazu. Das Buch. Und da spielt der Club halt sehr viel drauf mit an, also so durch die Galaxis zu fliegen, komische Sachen zu machen und sich einfach da durchzuhangeln.
Also eigentlich hatten wir mal so einen Camp gehabt. Und auf dem ersten Camp haben wir noch eine Rakete vom Kulturkosmos, also da wo die Fusion mal stattfindet.
Das war auch die Feridaste. Das war die erste Version der Feridaste.
Geklaut. Und irgendwann ist das natürlich dann so als Markenzeichen und Musstenmeld irgendwie in der Rakete.
Genau.
Weil der Munzen.
Ist auch das Tolle dabei. Ich meine, du hast ja ganz, ganz viele Sachen, die du damit machen kannst. Also generell so das Weltraumthema, ob es jetzt die eigenen Marketen bauen ist, ob es jetzt wie wir vorhin schon gehört hatten, halt mal Funknetzwerke aufbauen ist. Kannst aber auch, ja so, die Quadrocopter sind auch super toll geeignet. Also Quadrocopter, die diese kleinen, naja, selbstgebauten Drohnen, wie man es vielleicht heutzutage auch ganz gerne nennt. Ist halt super viel Technik drin, die man auch so für Weltraum nutzen kann. Die ganze Kreisel-Technik, die da teilweise verwendet, beziehungsweise auch die ganze Steuerungstechnik.
Also wenn man keine Propelloren mehr dran hätte, sondern Kreisel, genau, Motoren oder Kreisel.
Was sind die Kreisel?
Du hast immer Kreisel gesagt. Jetzt doch ganz schnell in einem Satz. Was sind Kreisel?
Stabilisatoren. Okay. Die drehen sich schnell und halten stabil, wie so ein Fahrradreifen.
So, jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit auch darüber gesprochen, was noch nicht funktioniert, was noch zu weit weg ist. Was sind jetzt so die nächsten Schritte? Also was wird denn in der Raumfahrt als nächstes passieren?
Ne, als nächstes passieren wird, also ist mal wieder ein weiteres Raumschiff zu bauen, um Menschen hochzubringen. Also es wird die Dragon Capsule zum Beispiel, die wird umgebaut für Menschen auch geeignet. Also das heißt, dass wir ein Raumschiff auch haben können damit. Ich denke, was auch passieren wird, sind viele kleine Forschungssatelliten auch in die Tiefen des Welts als reinzuschicken. Oder auch so Planeten, die schwierig zu erreichen sind. Merckow zum Beispiel ist sehr schwierig da hinzukommen. Diverse Monde mal beobachten oder mal besuchen gehen. Also Monde von anderen Planeten, die wir so haben. Auf ein Asteroid wird demnächst mal gelandet. Das ist auch was Neues, das habe ich bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Wofür ist das gut?
Um Asteroiden selber kennenzulernen. Was sind das für Dinge? Also bis vor wenigen Jahren, bis man einmal mit einer Sonne durch so ein Asteroid durchgeflogen, also durch einen Schweif durchgeflogen ist, wusste man gar nicht, dass es eigentlich nur so ein Haufen Schneematsch ist, der durchs Weltall fliegt. Also Eisklumpen.
Ja, es gibt ja zum Beispiel Theorie, dass viele organische Moleküle auf der Erde dann tatsächlich von Asteroidanschlägen kommen.
Das meiste von so einem Wasser kommt. Also das meiste Wasser, was wir auf der Erde haben, sind durch Asteroiden reingebracht worden. Ist durch Asteroiden reingekommen, ja.
Aber wo kommen die denn her?
Naja, irgendwo da draußen her, irgendwo aus der ortschen Wolke.
Wieder so ein Begriff. Ist das so, dass Raumfahrt auch das klären soll?
Ja, also man möchte wissen, wo das herkommt, woher auch dieser ganze Klumpen Schneematsch, Eismatsch herkommt und ob vielleicht eventuell in einem dieser Klumpen auf einmal schon so ein bisschen Leben drin war, was dann hier das komplette Leben auf der Erde auch sich weiterentwickelt hatte dadurch dann.
Und das hat irgendwann angefangen, Raketen in den Weltraum zu schießen. Und damit sind wir am Anfang der Sendung und damit beenden wir diese Sendung. Starbuck, Leon und Lars waren hier. Vielen Dank.
Wir müssen noch auf den Kongress hinweisen. Ach so?
Total, ja. Da steht die Rakete wieder.
Nicht, dass ich nicht gleich gefragt hätte, aber bitte?
Vom 27. bis 30. Dezember haben wir wieder den Chaos Communication-Kongress, nämlich den 30. dieses Jahr. Seit 1984 den 30. dann. Und das Ganze findet in Hamburg statt, im Kongresscenter dort, direkt neben dem Bahnhof Dammtor.
Noch viel größer als letztes Jahr.
Ganz viel größer, noch viel größer. Und Karten gibt es vor Ort.
Und mit mehr Raketen.
Es gibt vor allem genug Karten.
Also wer hinkommen will, soll hinkommen.
Dort gibt es also all things, die irgendwie was mit Chaos Computer Club zu tun haben. Falls euch mehr für Raumfahrt oder so interessiert und noch mehr hören wollt, könnt ihr übrigens gerne Raumzeit hören. Das ist ein Podcast, der ist von ESA und DLR, also Europäische Space Agency, European Space Agency und Deutsche Luft- und Raumfahrt-Gesellschaft.
Na gut.
Aber sozusagen, da gibt es noch viel mehr über Raumfahrt und Weltraum zu hören. Ich verabschiede mich, übergebe an Henrik Schröder, der euch gleich im Punk-Nightflight mit Musik bewerfen wird und habe natürlich noch eine Sache zu sagen und das ist möglicherweise wie immer. Lasst euch überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.